okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel
today i have a special guest um john in
the lifestyle he runs a channel with
about 25
25 000 subscribers and he's actually
probably one of the most practical
dating coaches i have seen
from a woman's point of view yeah i
appreciate that yeah i remember
when you emailed me you said that uh you
thought my advice was
like some of the most accurate you've
seen like what lines up with what
it's interesting because it was very
like data driven my whole approach like
very kind of a
scientific process so i always put up
like this exponential progression chart
that's really obnoxious in a lot of my
videos
but i really was just relentlessly
optimizing a system treating the
the dating game no different than poker
or chess or any other skill game that
you could
learn that has rules because there's
always you know you can you can just
take data on a lot of these things if
you if you were to just text whatever
versus texting like you know solid solid
text that have been proven to get more
meetups
and then you you test you know maybe a
different version of that and you can
keep comparing data
and eventually with enough data okay
this is these are the type sequences
that are leading to the most dates
these are the uh you know the ways that
i built the online profile to
to lead to the most matches or this is
how i'm running
my dates to bring the most groups home
like so every step of the process
i try to drive in optimization um so i
come from like a background of computer
science engineering
uh philosophy psychology etc i used to
work on uh
ballistic missile defense for lockheed
martin back in the day
and i've been doing this now for about
10 years and
the system's like working extremely well
at this point like it was already doing
a lot of the major pieces of it already
built by like 2012 2013
um and now it's just been like a
relentless optimization so
so now in the in the past year like when
i train guys
a lot even virgins a lot of them are
getting five to ten girls uh
new girls per month and just filling
their schedules with dates really quick
by like a week two or three of training
with me
so that's pretty much my my background
and story though
um well what i thought that made you a
little bit more credible was you started
off as like a nerd like i think a lot of
the pickup guys that i
see um they're already kind of
charismatic and good looking and like
good with women
so they don't really need as much game
um but just like seeing the
transformation pictures from you like
it was like 10 years ago um to now
that's like crazy
yeah so i was yeah i was probably the
shyest guy of like 700 people
and a lot of people can't like the way i
conduct myself on my channel now i speak
very
freeform and can be like boisterous and
swear a lot and stuff like that but i
was actually like super super shy i grew
up with social anxiety general anxiety
uh i was i was diagnosed with with
social anxiety disorder general anxiety
disorder obsessive compulsive disorder
more just like looping thoughts not like
ritualistic stuff and
like depression but just like all that
but but i think that's what gave me like
the hyper analytical powers so to speak
um i always had a knack for like
relentless
optimization um and systematic thinking
so it was like a hindrance on one on one
level and a blessing another in the
sense that it
allowed me to really break everything
down into its constituent parts and
analyze issues very clearly
um but yeah like the last year of high
school i was still
a virgin still hadn't kissed a girl i
didn't even kiss a girl until college
and i was raised in like a very
conservative traditional household we
weren't allowed to swear
me too yeah i was planning on waiting
till marriage have sex actually to the
so my parents are a bit horrified um
the current at the time of recording
this it's up to 1 384 girls and so and
my parents saw that on one of my sites
and they're like what's this about
so i don't think i really care at this
point but
um but yeah i was taking like seven ap
classes playing the violin playing
uh i was in math competitions and um
programming computers day trading stocks
and playing underground poker circuits
uh
chess tournaments so it was just like
the epitome of of nerdiness
video games i even was was uncomfortable
talking to other guys
for i had guy friends but it was more
like other super nerdy guys
and i never in many years would have
expected to be in this position it's
kind of like
revenge of the nerds because at this
point now i've lived in over 30
countries slept with hot girls around
the world and i don't i don't really see
any other
coach that has a system even close to
the results that mine puts out so
have you ever uh like how did you start
did you just start testing the different
theories and like measuring what worked
and then once you found something that
worked you just kept repeating it
no i actually built a lot of mystery
method um okay
so like i had a friend who ended up
doing a phd in quantum physics he was
one of my smartest friends and he was
like dude you got to read this book the
game
and this was probably like 2007 until
the 607
and i was like that sounds like a scam
that sounds like bs and he's like no
really like there's like actually like
a method to the madness here with women
there's like tactics and strategies
and i was like very reluctant it sounded
really kind of like bs to me
uh quite frankly and so i like i didn't
read i didn't bother reading it and then
after he read that he moved on to the
mystery method he's like this is even
more strategic
like far more strategic and he's like
this stuff's working i'm actually
getting results from it
and so then i was like alright [ __ ] it
i'll just yeah i still didn't really buy
into it but i was like
i'll just try it out and then after i
read the book the game
like that's like when the the pickup bug
set in and i was like this is [ __ ]
awesome
and i assumed there was gonna be like an
underground kind of society around the
world almost like fight club but i i
assumed it would be like guys that were
like extremely good because they had
this
um you know like they had these like
secret techniques and stuff and turned
out to be like just the opposite once i
finally met a group of pickup artists at
an rsd free tour
in 2012 and everyone was like super
weird and like
and actually like worse than the average
guy typically
which was kind of alarming at first but
um
but yeah i broke the first hundred girl
i had the first hundred girls in june
2012 that was just using mystery method
and i was starting to make waves on the
rsd nation forums
in 2012 and just like i i used i would
put a lot of like bragging in bravado
combined with like technical breakdowns
stuff like that so it'd be like a
headline like bang four new girls in 24
hours or
um you know had like three polls in a
night just doing crazy
[ __ ] that people hadn't really done
before seen before
and what's an example of like something
that you did so
like something that you learned from the
book that really helped
with mystery method yeah um just having
like a structure and
a methodology about how to move things
forward i think i think a lot of guys
get stuck about like okay after i open
what do i do
or like after we're talking like how do
i move this towards sex or you know
how do i um how do i how do i increase
my chances
so he like he had i don't know if you're
familiar but he had like the whole
like attraction comfort seduction model
and there was like sub phases in each
one
and it was all about like moving the
girl through the stages so that gave me
something practical and tangible that i
could implement and kind of measure
against how far i was making in the
process
and he had like strategies for each
level and to gauge how you're doing and
stuff like this
i think he's the guy respect most of the
community by far
i think he got a lot of stuff right and
i
i the problem is that he kind of like
froze it in time and he failed to like
evolve and optimize the system over at
as the years went on and also he he
missed on some things not not a lot but
i disagree with some things um but kind
of
the next big piece that that evolved all
this was i was put into a
group called uh top beast it was
supposed to be like the top 30 best
pickup artist in the world at that time
and we were on this forum it was called
topbeast.net or something
and it turned out i renewed a bunch of
the guys through various circles because
a lot of the top guys were meeting each
other because we had mutual friends
and they had selected us based on for
this group based on our field reports
and who was vouching for us and a bunch
of
factors and what i did was was just
vacuumed up all the knowledge from each
of these guys i befriended each of them
personally spent time with them
spent you know phone conversations
meeting in person etc
and i did kind of a mass comparative
analysis of what everyone was doing
and found kind of the common overlapping
key areas
and combining what i knew worked for
mystery method that was like the basis
of my
system today and then from there it was
just a hunt
for who can i find better than me at any
aspect of the game and i still
have kept that mindset all the way
through who who's getting better results
in day game who's
who's getting more their dates convert
who's doing better with texting who's
building their online profiles better
who's better retention
who's better getting strippers any any
little piece of it
and i was very humbled the whole way
through and still am
you know not ever seeing it is fully
mastered and always
trying to find people better so that
because instead of saying like no this
is my system
don't poke holes in it or whatever since
i had studied philosophy we were always
trained to do just the opposite so with
all my philosophical positions i would
circulate them to my
smartest friends and smarter professors
for the purpose of poking holes
so that i can make it stronger and then
i brought the same thing into the game
so if i could find someone better if i
could find someone that could find a
weakness in what i was doing
that was an opportunity to make the
system stronger and therefore produce
better results
so it was a process of trying to find
people better the whole way through
and also like just analyzing what was
happening at the different levels
and trying to drive in innovations as
well so like okay this area appears weak
or this area appears suboptimal
let me test this thing in this thing and
this thing okay now i found a better way
to do it
now i'm going to bring that forward so
it's a lot of iterative evolution and
optimization
and so it would but it kind of
culminated
i guess like in the year that i went
really hard like mid-2017 and mid-2018 i
was able to
close 246 new girls in a year so
it it definitely yeah which had like
diminishing returns because it was like
i was i wasn't working and it was like
well i haven't i haven't had a real job
since like 2013
and like an office job but um you know i
was just i was skipping the gym i was
eating like [ __ ] i was because there was
even not even a lot of time to eat
because there's
rotation girls and new dates all the
time um
but yeah that's that's kind of like the
process so so kind of like the bit the
the the big um
how do i say it kind of like the latest
guy that came onto the scene that i
found i could learn a lot from was alex
from playing with fire
and i've seen him stuff yeah he came out
in like 2017 or
2016 and i was like i think he's doing
some of this better than me with online
gaming texting that hadn't happened in a
long time
and so i hit him up and was like i can
help you but more both approach
and so we've been really close friends
ever since but
i wish there was more guys in the
community that actually had a
straightforward practical system
and that we could collaborate and break
new ground but it appears to be just the
opposite whereas like
probably 95 that's even upwards of maybe
99
have just massively over complicated
systems uh just plain
incorrect things all strewn all about a
lot of it's abstract and theoretical
and very very woo-woo and there's whole
whole communities whether it's like not
an
ounce of practical strategy anywhere
it's just a lot of guys talking about
either nothing you know nothing
just just like you know opinions and
attitudes and this and that
um like i think we're gonna get into
like the red pill stuff where it's just
a lot of
making guys confrontational resentful
towards women and they still don't know
how to get the women
or um you know just massively kind of
confusing them with rsds type stuff
where
they're kind of like kind of hamster
wheel buying products every year but not
really advancing in skill
well what i liked about your um your
method is it reminded me of my sales job
actually
um so i just liked that you had like
measured results
and how you can test everything and like
you actually can see like did i close
did i not close like that made sense to
me logically
rather than this like theories that
sometimes i hear in the red pill that
i don't necessarily see working all the
time yep
yeah yeah my my system of the modern day
is kind of like a sales funnel so like
at the very top you have your online
game night game and day game those are
like your three lead sources
right and then that all filters down to
phone numbers and the next big component
is texting
which i provided my products like
literally 100 percent like you know
unless she asks like some pointed
question you can just answer and go back
to the script
um but it gives you every control path
to go from a phone number to a date
every control path to go from a match to
a phone number
and then i show them how to run the
dates how to close the dates and how to
retain the girls so you can
you can look where your bottlenecks are
if you're not getting
you know the lead range i recommend like
10 to 15 or a more advanced level 15 to
20 leads a week
new phone numbers a week then you can
see you know where the errors are in
order to get the lead flow
uh handled but then when you get to that
point most guys are messing up the
texting
and then that leads to not many dates
when they get dates they're messing up
the dates that leads to not many girls
brought back home from the dates
and then when guys bring girls back home
they make closing mistakes as well
and then they can lose things there if
they get a hookup they don't know how to
retain the girl
so we really just diagnose each guy on a
custom level
here's here's the areas that are the
weakest and then we just drive and fix
this as quick as possible
and i've also optimized like how i drive
in fixes over the years as well so
the power of my my like mentorship
program here that i have in the
as my name here the plan i'm dating
system thing basically i'm plugging them
into the optimal strategy which is that
steep part of the exponential curve
and then when they hit a block or weak
point we just cleared away as fast as
possible because most guys are running
into the same types of
of blocks and sticking points to the
process
and so i know how to how to fix those
very quick and so we're just blasting
them
uh forward as fast as possible past all
their weaknesses and
plugging into all the optimal strategies
so i'm a firm believer that guys don't
need
months or years of practice or months of
years of training
to get extremely good they just need the
proper coaching
and the proper guidance and it happens
usually within two to three weeks
there's these giant levelings up how do
you typically see that
is it like they record their dates or
something like if let's say their issue
was a date how would you know
um well so basically yeah we i i have
them report back to me like where where
things are breaking down
we look at a lot of quantitative metrics
so let's say they were to go on
i i get them to level where they're
bringing home 80 to 90 of their dates
so if they go on 10 dates and they only
bring home like three or four girls or
two girls or zero girls
we see like okay are you sexualizing
your date
that's the guy's biggest problem
typically is they don't yeah
and they the girls see them two
platonically and puts them in the friend
zone
and then we look at are you setting
things up properly for her to come back
home with you
are you answering your objections come
back home with you are you letting the
conversation
fall flat right like so i have them
basically report back where things are
breaking down
then they make adjustments and then they
go and make it further or they or they
get the girl back home
and then they run into new problems so
that's why it's like um
it's like what i did in 15 to 20 years
i'm doing with each guy on a custom
level in a matter of
some short weeks so they're hit we're
getting them past some problems they run
in new ones get them passed again they
run some new ones
but it's a very clear direction how to
quickly fix each thing
versus like banging their head against
the wall and because i think the
the majority of guys in the community
are putting in a lot of time and effort
in some cases money with these other
coaches but they're not seeing any real
tangible results
and that's kind of the epidemic problem
that's been existing ever since the
the stuff came onto the the mainstream
is that
there's guys aren't seeing a return in
the time and effort they're putting in
and i would say that's almost
exclusively the fault of the coaches
across the board um and but the coaches
blame the guys
but the vast majority of my guys get
extremely good extremely quick so that
it's not the guys that's the problem
it's the coaches
do you are you able to help like um say
a guy that's like a below average earner
and below
average in looks um because i've heard
black pill
which um it talks about if like i think
if a guy is under the height of like
five five
his chant like 80 percent of women will
rule him out
some stat i don't know exactly what it
was um
are you able to like overcome that
through your course
so yeah any coach that says looks don't
matter is lying and i'm just saying that
for marketing
rst would emphatically and dogmatically
make that point for a long time
um i i say that looks do matter but i
tell guys to maximize and optimize your
sexual market value
and then just leave it at that so you
can't change your height you can't
change your ethnicity
what i found is that most guys get
centered in on this thing that they
can't change and they think that that's
the reason why they're not getting
results
so the guy thinks well i'm short so i'm
not going to get girls because girls
don't want a short guy or i'm i'm indian
or
asian and i don't you know so they're
not gonna like that if i'm in a western
culture so that's why i can't get girls
or it's because my hair is receding or
it's because
i'm too old or i'm too overweight and i
tell them that first of all that you're
just
fully handicapping yourself it's like if
you went into a car dealership and they
said like
hey we have this car over here and the
parts are all busted and it's all
rusting and the windows are
broken out do you want to buy it and of
course no one's going to want to buy
that and
that's how guys are presenting
themselves to the woman when they're
really defeatist in their head but that
doesn't mean that those things aren't a
factor
it's just typically not nearly as much
of a factor as guys think
and to whatever degree they are a factor
and you can't change it it's not
productive to to obsess about it
so like all things considered if you're
to take like a tall guy
like a tall white guy in a western
culture versus like a short ethnic guy
the tall white guy
on average will do better but i get all
kinds of
tall white muscular clients that that
haven't even been with 10 girls yet all
the time
so it's it's not like just because
they're tall or even good looking that
the girls are just going to magically
come into their lives they're still
usually making mistakes all throughout
the process
so and i've had tons of short clients
that that have
gotten multi-hundred uh late cons with
the girls so
uh those things matter but i tell guys
just try to improve the things that you
can
and then the rest of it is gain so the
re the rest of it is is your strategy
so it's not really productive to be
focused in on you know so if you
how that would work in practice for a
short guy is if you talk to a girl that
says you're too short or that she's not
interested or whatever because the guy's
too short
there's tons of others that will like
you even ones that are a lot taller so
who cares
is kind of how it goes
um what do you you talked about
objections
um that girls give and one of the things
you teach is overcoming objections
oh do you are you able to share the 14
objections or is that in your course
uh that's my course i mean i can i can
go over what they are i i just won't go
over like all my answers so like okay
the main one that the guys here like by
far anyone watching that's been to a
nightclub i'm sure you've heard this
countless times
as they say i can't leave my friends so
there's a different way to deal with
that in the first half of the night
versus second half tonight
because it's either a play and lots of
coaches say you can't pull in the first
half of night which is a myth
you just have to frame it different so
the first half a night it's all about
like let's go
like rip some shots at my place or go do
this and come back
versus second after night it's let's go
and then you know if if they insist
their friends
blah blah we'll just text them the
address or or whatever
there's various ways to handle that but
um yeah the objections typically come
from
the girl wanting to feel safe
comfortable uh make sure you're high
value enough etcetera so
um you know she's gonna say like what
what what if you're a murderer
serial killer that's another common one
yeah
what how do i get home we just got here
i'm not that kind of girl um on the
weekdays you'll hear a lot i have to be
up early
there's a specific way to deal with that
um
they'll say i can't come unless this
girl comes unless my whole group comes
um you know so i've identified 14 major
ones and i train guys how to answer
those
the same way that they do like in the
movie the wolf of wall street where
he's just training guys on a script i
literally have an objection
and answer uh sheet and and then
so in the exception the important uh
principle there is exceptions are the
rule
not the sorry objections of the rule not
the exception so
um it's it's very rare that you'll say
hey we should go out to my place and the
girl's like yeah let's go
she's simply going to say well i can't
leave my friends well if
like i can't hook up with you because we
just met
and those are all coming from different
places there's far less when you're out
with women
because the like because i'm living with
three girls in brazil now
when i go out to the clubs with them
there's like hardly any objections when
we ask the girls to come home because
other attractive females have already
vetted me
so to speak from a value standpoint a
safety standpoint etc
so then when we propose that the girl
comes with us
her value her you know her approval
circuitry uh
gets to kind of take a shortcut and the
whole like pre-selection
note shade and also like she just feels
more comfortable and safe with other
girls present
so but for the typical guy when he hears
that
objection or typically there's multiple
and on dates too and you want to go back
home after the date
um he usually thinks that means the
girl's not interested or he thinks that
like
okay like this isn't going to happen um
and i don't teach guys like don't it's
not about like not taking no for an
answer or something like
that it's more just this is like a
natural part of the process just like in
sales like you're in sales
um i have a friend who's like a top
salesman in this company
and he's really into the game too we're
close friends and he's like if a
prospect isn't giving objections they're
typically not even interested
if someone wants to buy they're going to
have objections and
it's just things they need cleared up
right like
if if she would ask like a real murderer
serial killer like hey what if you're
miraculous maybe they'll react a little
differently
or so it goes you know but but this is
stuff that she has to put out there in
the first place
and and it does do its job to weed out
the the weird guys
like i had a client once that was that's
he sent me a screenshot and the girl was
like hey i'll come over i just need to
make sure
that you're normal and he typed back
um well i like to wash dishes and i'm
also friends with dj tiesto
and the girl was like um bye and i was
like
and his whole like thought process was
like what would a normal person do okay
dishwashing is a normal activity and
then he tried to seem cool
by lying by lying and saying he knew dj
tso but that
did the job for her in the sense that it
like put up red flags
and i was i was like dude no you just
literally had to like actually be normal
not try to
be normal so um yeah it's interesting
because
but but if you don't know that in
advance that these objections are going
to come almost every time
then it's going to throw most guys off
like i'll hear guys in my coaching calls
oh i was bringing this girl home and
then she said she couldn't uh leave her
friends and so
i didn't end up bringing her back home
you know but they'll say that kind of
stuff in the beginning
and i train them how to deal with that
and then it's
you know and it's the same in sales it's
no one's
not known but a lot of times people are
going to have questions and concerns and
objections before they
before they make a purchase so it's kind
of the same deal
as a dating coach do you think that game
is more important than looks and status
or how would you how would you rank that
oh yeah far
far far more i would say i would say the
looks of the status is more just like
icing on the cake um
well first of all i've had i've had tons
of clients that have i mean
not many people really have much status
anyways um
they're just like normal guys but but
i've i've had tons of guys that were
average looking below average looking
um even guys that spent the last of
their money at my training and they were
fully broke that still ended up crushing
like
just just thousands of examples so
i personally don't even think it's a
debate because
i have empirical data to show
how so many guys that are avoidable that
like like you know
the guy guys of all varying levels of
looks and i consistently
get them very good and i think the look
stuff is mostly a threshold thing
then you can you can add your opinion
here because you're female but it's it
seems
to be the case a lot of girls have told
me this as well that uh it's it's mostly
just that the guy's like very overweight
or like
emaciated skinny or like um you know his
beard is all like out of control he's
not like or
not adhering to basic hygiene not
wearing deodorant or wearing like
clothes that just completely don't fit
and stuff like that
um um i would say that's true
on some level i think there's like a
basic like minimum every girl has
like for example i'm six foot so um
typically like i only date guys taller
than me but if like a guy
was i don't know interesting or
something i might go down to like five
ten five nine
yeah yeah i'm sick i don't know if you
know if you know but i'm 6'4
so a lot of guys say oh well it's easy
for you to say all this stuff because
you're 6'4
you're only getting girls because you're
tall yeah so i hear that all the time
you're only getting girls because you're
tall and white
or now that i've been living in brazil
oh it's because it's easy to get girls
in brazil which is not even true
but you know i arrived in brazil like
1179 girls so i was in the most
the majority of my girls were from
america anyways um
but yeah i mean yes what you said about
minimums yeah that's definitely true
and like a threshold thing but i just
tell guys not to get like
if they're wearing if they're adhering
to basic hygiene uh
working out you know taking care of
themselves etc
and not dressing not dressing like total
[ __ ] they don't even need to it's not
even like you need to go like revamp
your wardrobe like i just did a video on
my channel recently about
how to dress at the club 99 of the time
i just wore jeans and a button down
and i feel like that's like a good cross
between like not too casual not too
fancy
um and just like those you know shoes
that not sneakers but they're like
not super dressy they're kind of the
casual shoes
so you know guys overthink these things
i get guys on the phone that are like
well i think i think i could either like
get training game or i could go revamp
my wardrobe and sometimes they choose
the wardrobe and i'm like dude that
that should be like the icing on the
cake you need to learn all the strategy
first
and for those that think that it's just
a looks game or just a looks and status
game
um you can think just intuitively
logically that there's better ways to
text than others there's better ways to
run an interaction than others there's
better ways to run your date than others
etc
so i give them all like the key
structural things to move them through
the whole process
and that way they know what to do
they're no curveballs
anymore so they know like when i try to
bring the girl home and she says this
i do this when i you know when i try to
sexualize and she's not ready for that
here's how i back off like this and that
and that way the the whole all the path
kind of control paths are defined in
advance
and so because i think lots of guys get
confused about what to do when
when situations happen and it's not
always the
straightforward intuitive move that's
that's best and actually
you know lots of times isn't so without
being trained about those things in
advance
a lot of guys are are up against a lot
of opposition
from that and i've seen girls
simp over some broke like i'm talking
broke broke guys so i've always known
there's more to it
than just like the money that's often
like in red pill
um but it definitely it definitely helps
like you look at super rich guys and
they have like model girlfriends
but it's not everything because i'm
telling you i've had some like pretty
really pretty friends slip over guys
with like absolutely no money
yup yeah yeah that's what i'm saying
like some of my best
performing students were like flat broke
living at home
you know so and and the girl really even
knows how much money the guy has so
unless he's like living in squalor or
you know unable to afford like
a date or something the girl's not gonna
have any idea anyways
um so since we're talking about red pill
could you tell me um
some things that five things that you
agree with on red pill and then five
things you disagree with
um well like taking a step back first i
think i think like the
the whole movement itself is extremely
shitty and counterproductive and i've
spoken to lots of those guys on the
phone that are big fan boys of that of
those coaches
and of that stuff and they the very
common outcome after going through all
that material is that number one they
have still have no idea how to get girls
which is to me that's the most laughable
part number two
now they've almost gone backwards in the
sense that they're hateful and
confrontational and resentful towards
women
and uh number three like their role
models these guys that are coaches
don't produce receipts like they don't
show pictures them with hot girls
they don't show infield footage of their
abilities to pick up hot girls
and a lot of them even like shy away
from pickup artist stuff they're like oh
well we don't approach that
you know we've made that clear we don't
approach and to me i don't even
understand how you can be a dating coach
and not be good at and or not teaching
how to walk up to strangers in public
and and make some kind of
you know romantic or sexual connection
happen and spawn into a romantic or
sexual relationship
so um you know in in that sense
uh i i think the whole the whole thing
is is largely like a money grab
i think it's it's just and i didn't even
really tune into it until the past year
so i was seeing all the nonsense in the
pickup artist community
with guys being misled and then the red
pill seems to even be worse because at
least the pickup artists are trying
trying to give them a strategy even
though it's a pretty shitty one in most
cases
uh the red pill ones aren't even aren't
even trying to go down that path they're
not even trying to teach these guys
how to get girls they're just teaching
them you know
what seems to be just mostly theory how
to be the ultimate alpha and be in
charge on stuff but then i don't know
did you see my video where i
i showed behind the scenes how a lot of
them married uh
much less than desirable mates to have
girlfriends
like literally below average objectively
below average and people say oh that's
insensitive
but you know men can agree objectively
of a growth below average because of the
you know the traction circuitry that
we're hardwired with and
to me if if a guy is proclaiming to be a
guru
with women he shouldn't be with a below
average looking girl
she should also check a whole bunch of
boxes internally but if i had to pick
um five things can you can you list off
like the major
the major concepts in that thing and
i'll tell you if that would be a major
disagreement or major
agreement yeah um so one
red pill concept is that like being too
nice doesn't always get you results so i
think a lot of guys
went through like just being so nice
trying to give a girl
girl the world and then um they realize
they do that and they get cheated on
yeah yeah so but yeah but but
it's also like the other extreme is bad
and i think that they push the other
extreme
to just kind of like always have the
upper hand always always be in charge
and
and these guys are like resenting the
girls before they even get involved with
them because
they think the girls just like out to
[ __ ] them over or how to get them
so i advocate yeah being being spineless
or too much for a nice guy is obviously
very
very bad and going to lead to very bad
results and being walked on and stuff
but i actually advocate that guys treat
the girls well
but also have like a backbone and be
willing to call them on their [ __ ] but
but don't go in with this negative
mindset that you have to like
be one up or that you have to like be
ready for them to [ __ ] you over
for for me and some of the best like you
know best guys in the game
we've talked about this um you can treat
them well there's nothing wrong with
treating it real well like i treat all
the girls that i see very well
but when they [ __ ] up i make it very
clear that's not gonna be tolerated and
it's usually they get
one strike or a lot of times even zero
strikes if it depends on the the
severity of it
but um that's like the key difference
it's like
having a having a spine and also don't
be a people pleaser
you know if she says hey where do you
want to go out tonight oh it's up to you
babe
you know there's a lot of guys like that
that they don't want to actually like
have have an opinion on things or take
charge on anything or lead anything so
i think to answer to see how i weigh in
on that
they're right that it's bad to be the
nice guy and the people pleaser and the
spineless guy
but they're also advocating kind of
almost the other extreme
to you know where it just becomes like
misogynistic or it becomes almost like
um
like like woman like they're the enemy
or something and i think that's
extremely toxic and extremely
counterproductive
because i've met tons of cool girls all
around the world
and they also push that like lots of the
hot girls
are terrible and shitty and they're all
just like trying to [ __ ] you over even
more
because they have more options and it's
not and that's
some of the best girls i met were also
very hot you know so
and i think that's misinformation as
well i don't think those guys even have
experience dating hot girls
if they did they would show it and they
never show it
and you can just talk about how they
carry themselves the hot girls wouldn't
respond well to them anyways
well that's actually one reason that i
i kind of started questioning some of
the pickup artists a little bit
um because i don't know i consider
myself pretty average
and i'm like why don't i want to sleep
with these guys if they're so good
like good at this stuff you know well
that's the thing is like they get
together with like 10 of them on a
stream
and never once do you see them with
women never once do you see them
showing proof of getting women and which
is mind-boggling because like in in
almost every field like imagine if you
just had a basketball player that only
had a youtube channel and there was no
footage of them playing basketball in
any games
it kind of seems like that like in the
dating community literally anyone with a
with a
webcam or a camera can just go on and
say literally anything and i think like
one of the best examples of that is
fresh and fit where you have a couple
guys like i don't know if you've seen my
videos on those guys
but basically like they're not good with
girls
and they just go on and and pretend that
they're experts at it or pretend that
they're just like huge ballers and all
that stuff
and what's fascinating there is like
okay everyone just buys into it
like no no one gives a [ __ ] you know and
also like
people feed into all the drama and all
that but it's it's like nonsense it's
it's basically just like trash reality
tv or like almost like a jerry springer
type thing
where where myron is like you know doing
these kick
outs all the time and this and they just
realize right away this is what's
getting views
just just treating the girls on the show
badly and and doing calling them out
over nothing all the time and kicking
them out
over nothing all the time and people
love that and but that's what people
loved about jerry springer
they didn't really give a [ __ ] what the
what the issue was they just liked the
drama between
the different people on the show so i do
give them credit that they that they
grew a channel
really fast and really big and stuff
like that but in terms of like
possessing real expertise or being real
gurus it's like
not even close right so like the one guy
was working for wix.com like six months
ago
right like was married to a not so
attractive
girl and and but then they just go on
and they make all these claims
and there's no and there's no fact
checking in the industry and that's
where i come in
so i have like um
you know a lot of these guys [ __ ]
hate me and they're they they put
slander videos and and posts and um
there's like paid seo against me and
so i take a lot of uh repercussions for
that but i think it's important
for guys to know oh hey by the way all
these idols that you worship and spend
so much time watching
and think are like the absolute man uh
by the way they have
like next to zero skills with girls and
and they're married to a girl that you
would never even want to talk to
but that's a secret right and even
though they have huge channels who gives
a [ __ ]
and then they all just kind of cross
promote each other and cross rep each
other
and it's like this this glass house
you know it's like this whole facade
that they've all built up and i kind of
came in
and brought a wrecking ball through a
lot of that in the past six months with
some of the videos i did in these guys
and it wasn't yeah i forgot i wasn't
like a lot of people think oh he's just
jealous or trying to be a hater or
you know just trying to uh you know
cause problems they could cause
it's really because i value this game so
much and i devoted the vast majority of
my adult life to it
you know and put put lots of like blood
sweat and tears so to speak into
optimizing it
and to me they've like me a lot of these
guys have made like a circus out of it
in the sense that you have guys that
don't know what they're doing that have
[ __ ] systems and [ __ ] results in lots of
cases
uh pretending to be like the ultimate
authority in this area
and and they get away with it in in on a
large scale
and it's it's mind-boggling some of the
most successful
uh products in this niche have been
full-out scams
and they just had a very good marketing
message and i
and i've spoke to thousands of guys on
calls and seen the forums over the past
decade
of all the the carnage that that's
caused they've ruined tons of lives
lots of guys have given up hope with
women completely lots of guys were
driven to being suicidal or having mass
depression some guys had mental
breakdowns
and i would say like the vast majority
of the guys
this is still a major problem and they
still don't have no idea what to do or
where to turn and all these people that
promised them help have have failed them
and failed them
on purpose but they've but they've
extracted
these guys time and and money and uh
spit them up
you know chewed them up and spit them
out and and i
i don't know it's not like i feel like
oh i need to be like the
the hero here to like tell everyone
what's what it's it's just i've just
been so sick of it for so long
and to me it's just like straight up
corny that you know i could just grab a
random person off the street
and say hey go on camera and say you've
done all this stuff in the game it's
just really corny
it's like a big disgrace to the to the
game itself
and the fact that these guys get wildly
popular with all their nonsense claims
and
you know that's why i always say like
they need to show
pictures they've gotten hot girls they
need to show and feel footage of taking
these girls home
hardly any of them have that right and
so
yeah i don't think most of them can be
trusted and then you when you feel
behind the curtains
surprise surprise they have a really
ugly wife that's a secret
well that's the thing you have i feel
like people can't even say you're not
legit because you have a ridiculous
amount
of credibility when it comes to evidence
of all of these hot girls like i saw you
pick up a model
in new york city that was on fashion
week
yeah and yeah in that particular video
she ended up having a boyfriend and like
i didn't even end up banging that chick
guys were asking the comments
like hey did you sleep i'm like no
that's other things like i'm never gonna
even if people can't verify i'm never
gonna just go and lie about something
that didn't happen
in the game because to me that's [ __ ]
corny but
but yeah i do have there's there's
countless amounts that i haven't even
released
of pictures with girls hidden camera you
know the pickups in public
uh the infield footage with girls and
and
yeah you're right i think i have more
proof than the entire rest of the
industry
there was one guy named radicus that had
all his accounts shut down on youtube
and instagram and stuff like that and he
was showing a lot of proof as well
but not counting him i feel like i have
more proof than all the rest of the
coaches combined
but then since i take them on like full
force and pretty aggressively
they'll go on and make active slander
comments like i actually have a
active lawsuit going against modern life
dating because he went on and
slandered me in like these three two
hour long videos
um you know and people are making fake
reddit posts and
it's really [ __ ] annoying because
they're
they're making me out to be like worse
than these all these faking guys
you know people just make like
sensationalist reddit posts about me
just because
i've made a lot of enemies doing you
know calling these guys out
and they'll say oh worst pickup artist
in the world worst coach in the world
and i'll just write a whole bunch of
slander nonsense oh he's paying he paid
for all his girls yeah 1384 girls were
all paid
you know or all his all his hidden
camera footage oh but that's all fake
too those
girls almost be paid so here you have
guys with zero evidence
saying that this guy with mountains of
evidence endless evidence more than all
of them combined it's all fake
right and it's and it's all facade and
they give people believing this
and it's you know it's sad what's a
common piece of dating advice that
you've heard
from the red pill that you just think is
absolutely wrong like something that
your clients come to you and you just
you cannot believe that they
told them to do that um
all the all the like trying to make
women chase you stuff is really stupid
okay like like going back to the sales
analogy
like imagine if you had a bunch of sales
prospects and instead of like following
up with them
to get you know appointments to try to
close the sale
um which is what you're doing when
you're texting and setting up dates
and you just like let it all ride and
hope they came
to you so like there's there's red pill
coaches that say like don't even
take the girl's number give your number
out uh after a date wait for her to text
you
you know all this kind of stuff but and
that stuff might sound good in theory
but it's
it's like god awful in practice because
in practice
uh you're dealing with like the lead the
phone number eroding over time
as each day goes by the girl's thinking
of you less and less
and if you if you just had a brief
interaction or maybe even just one date
you're not like the forefront of her
mind especially like you know
in the very beginning when you guys
haven't interacted that much
so all this like play it cool and and
let her come to use stuff
um typically backfires and and the girl
in the lead will just go cold and they
lose the girl
it gets some of these stalemates kind of
where like the girl's not responding and
so the guy is going to play cool and
wait for
you know he's going to wait for her and
they're kind of waiting on both sides
and then nothing happens and the girl
moves on so
especially if she's like a nine or a 10
because they'll say like oh if you're
high value the girls will come to you
and i think that's true on some level
but if a girl is a nine or a ten do you
think you're the only high value guy
trying to talk to her
yeah they have like yeah they have
unlimited options
so the whole notion of like um
you know playing like i tell guys for
instance in a lot of guys think this is
wrong but
i can assure them that it's not um like
when a tinder match comes in for
instance
the best strategy is to hit her up right
away because that means that she just
swiped on you she was just looking at
your profile
and she's active on the app right then
so i'll hit her right away with the
opener if i notice it come in
and if she responds i respond instantly
with the next message as well
and after like three back and forth i
move her to the phone and then we have a
quick back and forth and
and a date is set up so that process
happens in like two minutes
whereas if you like see the match come
in you're like okay i don't want to
look too eager or after your first
message is answered you're like i'm
gonna just let this ride i don't want to
look too eager
now you just got buried in her queue of
messages because she's attractive and
getting inundated
and now like you miss your shot
altogether and very
well likely may never meet her right so
that a lot of this stuff
also also like the the notion of um
being a provider
like you should never buy a girl a drink
you should never buy a girl at dinner
out
um that's all [ __ ] too and and i've
seen
countless guys lose girls because they
didn't want to pay for uber or because
they you know like i've even had clients
on live programs they're about to leave
the club with the girl
and they're just grabbing a drink on the
way out and and the client will think oh
i i can't be a provider here
uh hey let's split this or hey better
yet can you pay for this drink
and the girl just leaves because she's
like what the [ __ ] is this guy's deal
that doesn't that doesn't mean if you
buy a girl a drink they're like you're a
huge sim provider but a lot of guys
internalize that
and they think that they're like
spending any money on a girl in any
situation
makes you a loser which is absolutely
ridiculous
well and that's what i thought too
because if a guy
i don't know like i can buy my own
dinner or whatever but if a guy
asked to split the date i would just
assume he wasn't really that into me
because i would be i would i would like
the way i think i would think oh if
there was like a better looking girl he
would probably pay
if he was super into me so i would
probably just like
not call him or you know keep talking to
him because i would assume he's not into
me
yeah it's just a stupid principle where
a guy is like
like you can't be nice to the girl
because then she's gonna lose respect
for you you can't buy anything for the
girl because then you're just going to
be a beta bucks provider ship
you know that's kind of [ __ ] or or
like um i'm trying to get some other one
oh like
being reactive right like like oh you
always must keep an even keel
but but in reality the real players and
the guys that are crushing like
like i've been with well over a thousand
girls i know for a fact like
it's fine to buy girls drinks at bars
it's fine to pay for dates if you invite
a girl on a date
you know that's a normal traditional
expectation it's fine that doesn't mean
you need to go shower her with gifts all
the time uh you know or be like kissing
her ass
if you want to be nice to like like you
know caught like being endlessly nice
and all
in all situations but i feel like a lot
of this they go to the other extreme
and they put these dogmatic rules down
like rollo has a i just did a video on
this rolo has a video
or a iron rule of tomasi that says
um never cohabitate with a woman and i'm
cohabitating with three beautiful
brazilian girls
in a two-story penthouse along the water
and i have 14
girls on the side for side rotation and
we all go out and pick up girls together
they run their own tinders and bring
girls into the house it's so i have like
kind of the best of all worlds here
but um you know the notion that you
can't
cohabitate with a girl is ridiculous um
they have all kinds of there's coaches
in the red pill community that say that
you can't even um
what's it called uh like you shouldn't
even approach
there's a whole choosing signal i just
learned about this like three months ago
like alpha male strategies i like i i
did a video where he where he was
literally like
hey guy he was on a live and he's like
hey guys i'm gonna approach the next
snow bunnies that that come by
and then there's a group of like three
girls and then he told the cameraman
like hey you do
you do and he's like totally chickened
out and to me that was like
and people were defending him in the
comments and like well he's he's made it
clear that he doesn't approach
he waits for choosing signals and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that and they're
like oh it's like
the girl uh showing some interest in
advance like
like looking at you and stuff and i was
like that's total [ __ ]
like like yes that that could be a thing
like if the girl is
staring at you or comes over in close
proximity that could be an invitation to
approach
but by no means uh there are lots of
girls doing that or any kind of majority
doing that like
the man still needs to take initiative
in the vast majority of the cases
so you know the stuff that they push out
there and then guys watch that okay i
don't need to approach anymore
and what's that going to do for the
results they already had [ __ ] results in
the first place
so there's like layers and layers and
layers of incorrect
uh strategy being pushed out and the
common man is [ __ ] and the problem is
he he worships these guys and holds them
in such high regard
and it's almost like a call like with a
lot of these coaches
they they get drawn into this guy's you
know on-screen presence or whatever and
his [ __ ] claims and [ __ ] persona
and then they think like okay whatever
this guy says is like
law this is this is basically like god
right like rst tyler i think is one of
the best examples
he's like a short unattractive super
weird redhead
and i've been out with him a bunch and
and i've asked girls that he's talked to
afterwards what did you think of him
weird gay creepy awkward cringe you know
like
they're not like oh but then on camera
he's like yeah i'm up all night [ __ ]
models and
and i wake up late in the day and and
i'm oh there's all these texts for girls
begging for me to come [ __ ] them
he's saying that he's getting approached
multiple times a day even when he's not
dressed well
it's you know it's classic example of a
guy just going on and hyping
the [ __ ] on himself with fake stories
and i caught him in countless lies
but the average person that watches his
stuff they think he's like literally the
ultimate player
and so they're ready to like buy all his
programs and they have over 30 of them
and they keep coming out with new
solutions each year and they've gotten
more and more clever now that now they
don't even sell boot camps by themselves
that
they have an option to do for buy a pack
of four boot camps
and you know i i just bought a review on
my channel where we had seven
polls out of eight guys seven guys took
girls home out of eight one of the
nights
in a program that uh was run under my
company last week
and you don't need more than one program
if it's done properly
my whole thing is it's my training is
the permanent and final solution
if i didn't get the guy very good that
means i didn't do my job
whereas the rest of these guys i think
are purposely trying to keep them on a
hamster wheel
so because if they if they fix the
problem they lose the customer
right so it's yeah are there any coaches
in the red pill that you think have some
credibility
like some of the stuff they say might be
okay
i hate all of them
nice i actually i don't think ams
is that bad i don't agree with the
choosing signals things but i've seen
some videos that i don't think are that
bad
well he yeah him and i like chatted back
and forth at one point he claimed 450
girls
which i guess i could buy into um
but the problem with his stuff is it's a
lot of like uh internal
internal frames and stuff like that
there's not much strategy anyone that's
not giving like
a lot of like explicit uh outer game
strategy i have a problem with
because you know all the mindset stuff
is only going to get you so far
it's like that you know it could be true
for making money online or any any other
area where a guy's trying to make
progress it's not
solely about um you know just
just getting the mindset down um
but yeah i just noticed the comments
here
um someone that said she always forgets
to reply to my text what would be your
solution would you tell him to just move
on
or would you tell them it's very common
that the girls don't respond reply to
texts and i've even done experiments
where i've like
made like a perfect 10 instagram profile
um
and and the girls stall that guy's mess
he'll match like way way way more but
they'll stall his messages
on the app and over text to shitload too
the very the very
uh nature of like you know modern
technology is that the people's
intentions
are just torn in a whole bunch of
different places you have no idea what
she's doing
at the time that you're texting or
messing with tinder and
so many guys are hitting her up and so
many people are hitting her up
that i i'm all about aggressive
follow-up so i have like a go-to text
after the first on reply the second
non-reply and the third non-reply and
they all have very high chances of the
girl responding back but it shouldn't
respond back after those three
then you know you can do like some kind
of hail mary move or take away move but
you typically don't want to be involved
with a girl that's that's not responding
to those three anyways
someone said why is john using a green
screen but he lives in a tiny apartment
there's a two-story penthouse
on the water in brazil with three hot
chicks it's actually a giant place
but it is the the room i recorded with
the desk is a little bit smaller and
people thought it was like a basement or
some [ __ ] so this is a better background
yeah they've been freaking out about the
green screen the whole video
um have you heard about kevin samuels at
all
yep yeah apparently fresh and fit like
copied all everything that he said
so i'm not super familiar with him
personally but i know that
like pretty much everything fresh and
fits say is just a copy of him
um so he talks about because this is
just from the girls point of view that
if you want like
to increase your value as a girl it's
about being fit feminine and friendly do
you think that's true
feminine yeah the man should be feminine
no no as a girl i'm asking so
he talks actually more to women than he
does men i think he used to talk to men
but he like
blew up from talking to women
okay um the girl should be fit feminine
and friendly
yeah that's what he says yeah whenever
it grows because because i've met
tons of hot girls around the world when
they find out what i do they're like
what's what's the game for girls
how do girls get better and yeah like
you know for better or worse
uh a man is assessing a woman's value
largely based on her physical looks at
least at first
so i think like gym and makeup and like
eating well is like
very important and then i think like the
next big piece is like
um i don't know the best way to phrase
it but just don't be like very [ __ ]
like
like you know confrontational causing
problems trying to play power
struggle games all the time doing lame
stuff anything that kind of
classifies as like [ __ ] or something
like that
um you know which a lot of girls try to
do um
yeah beyond that yeah just being like
friendly and cool and also not being
like
overly because girls can be needy too i
i meet girls
that that are just blowing up my phone
all the time i lose attraction pretty
quickly
when they're like hitting me up a lot um
or like if i don't respond to a message
which a lot of times i don't even see it
for a while
and then they're like you know this
they're like kind of like melting down
it's it's funny because girls will like
send question marks and sometimes they
try to send like
provocative pictures and if you like
leave them on red after seeing like a
nude or a sexy pick
like that never happens to them so they
start like
they start like self-destructing yeah i
think i think the
looks component is huge just because of
how men are
are wired and then beyond that i think i
think it's important but i don't i'm not
just superficial where it's only hot
girls like i want the girl
i like a very strict quality control for
the internals as well i want the girl to
be
like ambitious and smart and fun and
cool and like
i can bring around my friends and like
you know she adds up a bunch of value to
my life in various ways
and we can like work on stuff together
and you know all kinds of stuff like
this
so um i think i'm different than most
coaches because i run big rotations
these guys aren't even capable of doing
that but i typically run like
10 to 15 girl rotations over the past
couple years in poland before brazil was
like 17 girls
and i have a pretty close connection
with each of the girls and like i like
going out with on dates
i like hanging out with them a lot of
the coaches are just very focused on
like banging the girl and kicking her
out as soon as possible
which i do sometimes you know but i
actually enjoy the the
time with the girls enjoy the connection
with the girls and there's a lot more
with a girl than just sex to get you
know to to grow with and have enjoyment
from
i think a lot of coaches get it wrong
when they they tell the guy oh she
doesn't bang on the first date don't see
her again
a lot of the the nine pluses that i
banged over the years
took two dates and i think a lot of them
on principal don't bang on the first
date
just because they have a million options
and i'm just gonna go around banging
everyone
um and also i think like
um yeah i mean just just just standing
out basically just being the best
version of themselves having lots of
[ __ ] going on
is definitely gonna help things as well
but yeah for better or worse the looks
thing is
is a huge component for most guys um
someone wants to know would he make a
girl from mcdonald's his main chick
um possibly
it depends so i i'm going to be 38 in
october
um but i still write regularly bang
girls 18 to 23
range so she was like young and and uh
if that was like her final
stop in terms of her career almost
surely not
um but but if she was my main chick
um no typically my main trick is like
uh like elegant and educate like like
the main girl i'm seeing in brazil
that i bring on my channel a lot um
she's a civil engineer she's hyper
analytical like myself
um we have like lots of like silly
inside jokes and stuff like that
um but you know like i want i i want
like a
girl that i can have like intelligent
conversations with and and stuff like
that as well
as the main chick because we have a
strong emotional connection
i don't think i would i would want a
main chick to just have surface level
hotness
so they're typically like a full package
girl the the number one number two spots
but but i definitely would have it right
down on rotation no question
um do you care about body count is that
something you care about
because my brain when i think about like
the methods that you're going through i
would imagine like these girls have like
crazy high body counts and a lot of guys
that's like a big turn off for them
um what do you mean do i care about it i
care about it from a skill standpoint i
think that
um like when i i've since the beginning
i've always like
emphasized it and by by the beginning i
mean like when i started getting active
on the forums i was already over 100 i
was i had 100 in
june 2012. and then i i always kind of
would announce okay at 200 300 400 500
i had a thousand now and i i think that
um
it's it's a good objective metric of
overall skill and experience in the game
so i meant i bet for the girls you date
oh
um yeah it's a big turn off if
it's uh probably like higher than like
20. i feel like a lot of the
the girls i've dated it's in like the 10
to 20 range or 5 to 20 range
um if if the girl is like 100 plus
that's like a pretty big turn off for
me and i wouldn't get that serious with
her because
you know typically a girl like that um
that i'm just thinking across the ones
that i know that have a comment that
a lot of them had like childhood issues
or they have like very big insecurity
problems or very big self-esteem
problems
and they have like this void they need
to get filled anyways
where they're going to still want to
keep that going with we're seeing
seeing guys or attention with with jives
and stuff or with guys and stuff like
that
um let me see here
i'm supposed to jump to another thing
but we can we keep going
okay no it's fine because i have a one
of the guys in my company is going to
get on the meeting
so um but yeah i don't like to me that's
it's kind of gross and
they'll say to me like oh but yours is
over a thousand like it's a double
standard
but that's true but i i don't wanna
i wouldn't wanna get like close to a
girl that's
that's [ __ ] a lot i guess that has a
lot of sexual experience but like i like
it
i like it more of the opposite not like
a virgin but like like the three
the three girls i'm living with um i was
like their first threesome i was their
first four son
uh i like like introducing them to those
worlds and
and then and enjoying it together rather
than um
you know going going to some like
hardened veteran in the dating game i
guess
no i mean i totally understand like the
low body count thing from a guy's
perspective
it just makes me think if a girl is
sleeping with you on the second date
that her body count would be higher
um so i'm surprised that like the girls
you know less than 20 for all of them
because my thing is like i would think a
girl sleeping with someone on the second
date it would be close to like 50.
yeah and yeah a lot of them are lying
too so
so who knows the real numbers for a lot
of these girls but yeah um
yeah i would say like statistically like
once once the guy's game is good i i
close 80-90
of my dates on the first date i would
say it's only it only doesn't happen if
the girl has like a hard rule
about hooking up with a stranger on the
first date or um just a hard rule about
you know waiting to get to know each
other more and stuff like that
um or in a place like ukraine whether
they're super prude but
um yeah i yeah so that's definitely
something to balance
i make it pretty clear that it's going
to be like one way monogamy with all the
main ones
where i don't want them seeing other
dudes and there's like not even a
warning
if they end up going to do that which
they usually don't but
for all 17 or 15 you said or is it just
the main ones in the house
um it's so it's it's usually just like
the the ones that like the most
important it's almost like there's like
three tiers
i've noticed with the rotation it's like
all the all the hottest coolest ones
those are in like tier one
tier two and then when you have the
emotional connection with those and tier
two would be like
you know they're still hot and they're
still cool but there's like less
emotional connection
and then tier three is like you don't
really have almost any emotional
connection it's mostly just sex
and i still try to keep the quality of
those high i try to keep like around
rotation like above and eight
at least out of ten you know not to
objectify anything but
at least in terms of like physical looks
they're all still pretty attractive
but i like flake and and de-prioritize
and cancel a lot on the
on the ones in tier three and then it's
always like
um you know shifting based on if one of
the girls [ __ ] up or i get bored or
one of the girls comes too annoying or
demanding too much time or attention
whatever
then i just replace and girls can move
up in categories and stuff but
um with the top ones like the tier one
ones a lot of them
know my job and they know that i'm gonna
still be seeing other girls and i don't
want them ever seeing
another dude and sometimes there's push
back on that because they'll say like
uh that's not fair why do you get to do
that and i can't or like their friends
get in their ear and they say hey that's
you know it sounds very one-sided
[Music]
um but i just make i just tell them like
i know it's double standard
but it's non-negotiable and it's not
meant to be like a
you know ruling like you know like a
dictator or something like this like oh
i
take it you know but it's more like i i
just tell them
like the way andrew tate put it when i
did an interview with him on youtube
because he lives with two girls and then
he has four other girlfriends in a
different house so he has like six
girlfriends
and he said he tells the girls like i'm
a high value guy
i can get girls no problem um i have two
choices i can either be up front with
you i'm gonna be seeing other girls or i
can lie to you about it which do you
want
and and the girls are like well just you
know we can be upfront about it
i also don't want you being with any
dudes and that's just how it is
that's pretty much how i how i phrase it
too but but you make sure the girl is
like very into you before you
but that can happen as your game gets
better they fall for you pretty
pretty fast and you you guys can be
pretty close ready after one or two
dates
um but there's a lot of appeals
to you know like i i [ __ ] them really
good we have tons of fun um i've had a
lot of life experiences and lived all
around the world and speak like five
languages and so
they're like that they all say that it's
like this whole new world for them
now they're having like all this group
sex and like
yeah they're just it's just it's just
cool there's it's it's like a new
a new world like most people's lives are
really boring they're just going through
jobs and
you know doing a social thing here or
there but there's not like it's like a
new big adventure every day
for for everyone in the house and for
the the girls we have over and stuff
like that and it's
um so so we hear from the other girls
that come in the house that they just
love being here they feel really free
there's like a stripper pole in the
house
they they can be very there's like it's
not like hippie style like oh
only good vibes only or some [ __ ] like
that but
it's just it's just like a place where
there's not really any like societal
conventions and stuff like that and i'll
be like the only dude we'll
we'll go out to a club it'll be like
seven girls and me or like
they'll be like a whole bunch you know
we've even had like 10 girls here and
just me
i'm the only guy um and you know
it's just it's cool the girls all become
friends with each other
and we're all laugh and and have fun but
but i bang all of them
and that's i guess maybe it's like
old-school tribal
[ __ ] where it's like the tribal leader
or something but i think that's the
natural state of how
uh men and women are were meant to be
anyways five percent of mammals are
monogamous
so a lot of those institutions drove
that stuff in but it's not normal
um no that's actually really interesting
i'm trying to be respectful of your time
no no you're you're good don't worry
about that
my business associate is on that other
meeting so it's good it's okay okay
because we can i could go for another
like 20 minutes but i don't want to
like go too long no you keep going
it's all good wait so um
so these girls are actually cool with
that that's that's crazy to me because
i'm very like
i'm very jealous and i don't i i don't
think i could ever like do something
like that so this is not
it's not all right it's not all rosy
like there's there's plenty of uh drama
especially like in the accommodation in
the beginning
so like it's going against the thing is
is like the societal
constructs are like pretty strong it's
like what they've known their whole life
are mental models of things and again
like i said i was raised
like you only you never drink you never
never have sex before marriage right you
never swear
all this stuff so i i went through all
like the shell shock of breaking away
from that
you know a long time ago but um you know
just the whole notion of like
okay you're sure they're sharing me
because they'll fall in love with me and
then they say like
well i have to share divide my time
between these other girls and so you
know so there's like growing pains for
sure
it's not all like well you talked about
you talk about building
investment which i right that's the word
you use
yeah yeah it comes from history um yeah
so that's actually an interesting
like that totally makes sense to me like
the more time a girl has spent getting
to know
you and like um like dating you and
stuff the more likely she is going to be
willing to like put
up with different but basically like
like
cup like things that initially she might
have said no to like the one-sided
monogamy or the
would you call it um
yeah like yeah one-way monogamy
basically yeah
yeah so mystery mystery would always say
like um
the like the three major forms of
investment there's like temporal from
spending time with each other
physical from hooking up and then like
emotional from uh getting to know each
other and getting feelings for each
other and getting attachment
and as you qualified that
in the beginning then you hit like a tip
over point where now she's like a
regular so to speak
but now you have like a lot more leeway
to to [ __ ] up
right because if you if you make any
misstep in the in the very early on days
like especially like when you're on the
app
or on text there's like zero investment
so it's easy for her to just next to you
or block you or whatever
um but once once she's like okay i like
this guy
he makes me feel good i'm curious to get
to know this guy more
now you have a situation where you can
get away with like almost anything no
not that
i'm not talking about that like in a
sense like oh let's test the limits
but they're more open to want to go
along with
with what you're proposing especially
when there's a lot of positives to it
so you know there is a negative there
there is like the jealousy stuff and
this and that but
um i try to like keep a nice balance in
the house like
out you know i was just at lunch with
one of them
today i went for coffee with another one
it's nice to spend time with some of
them one-on-one
um instead of just all doing stuff
together so they feel
appreciated and stuff like that so um
but yeah i remember talking to andrew
tate i'm like dude like you can
appreciate the amount of drama that
comes along with this he's like yeah it
can be a nightmare sometimes
it's just a lot for them to handle
sometimes because um
but it's pros and cons you know we're
all very supportive of each other and
when anyone's having trouble in their
life
or in any kind of situation but from you
know
the whole part about like if i go to
like cuddle with one of the girls out of
the three
and the other two like you know don't
have me cuddling them and then they're
seeing you know there's like little
stupid things like that
and those that has evolutionary roots
too it's like because
um you know they they want the man to
like provide for the young and protect
the young and stuff like that and if
he's
being involved with someone some other
woman then that could have like
disastrous consequences
so but andrew tate said he tried to
introduce like his his world view and
like break the old paradigms
and break the societal constructs and
so we kind of it's like us against the
world like kind of like
partners in crime like we're living this
um
kind of different revolutionary style
life and
and it does have tons of really cool
benefits
um you know like we go out to the club
like we we've pulled all kinds of girls
home together
but worst case scenario if we don't pull
anything we still before some you know
so
well i think girls in general get more
mad over like the emotional
like if i if i had a guy cheat on me i
think i'd be
like more mad if he hooked up with like
a regular girl that he knew versus like
a hooker
yeah so i i could see like do you do you
see that when
with multiple girls yeah they've done
studies that uh and this has
evolutionary roots as well they've done
studies where they've found that
the man is more upset by the woman like
[ __ ] another dude and that's because
like if you were raising some other
dude's kids that would be like a huge
disaster and if you didn't know it
um but the woman cares more about the
man
like catching feelings for a chick and
and like falling in love with the chick
and stuff like that
so i try to tell them like the girls on
the side i don't have any emotional
connection with
which isn't entirely true you know but
but um i tell them to think of
the girls on the side like the 14 on the
side to think of them more
almost like uh glorified sex toy you
know not to not objective because
it's easier for them to like rationalize
that way um
that these are just girls that i'm just
having fun with and
it's not we don't they don't have like
what we have
on our level and andrew tate said like
his girls know like just because some
new like shiny
you know he's like this girl has like a
really nice set of tits that the main
girl in the house isn't gonna like lose
her [ __ ] because she has like years of
history with him
so yeah there is kind of like that um
but we're it's like it's like a learning
process because
i have never cohabited with three girls
before and that
you know and they haven't either and
we're all kind of like making
adjustments as we go i try to keep
everything open if someone's like upset
about something we try to
discuss it get it out in the open make
adjustments
and you know make sure everyone's like
happy and having fun and everything's
cool and stuff like that
um but yeah like i said pros and cons
it's not
i talk about a lot of the benefits in
the channel but it's not just pure
um fun all the time and there's high
quality problems too like
they [ __ ] blocks a lot of times when i
want to like bring other girls over
just because there's there's two floors
in the house and and there's
a lot of space and stuff like that but
easier when there was just two girls in
the house
before the third one moved in um one one
could be at work like doing her
engineering job
the other one might like run out to get
groceries or do some [ __ ] have a girl
over
or if just one girl's in the house she
can just chill in her room or even when
two girls in house they can chill in
their rooms sometimes
but with three it's it's a little more
tough to like put them all away in the
room and plus they can hear me
banging the girls and [ __ ] like that and
sometimes that pisses them off
they'll just hear me like bang a girl
for like an hour straight with like the
[ __ ] floor in bed all shaking
upstairs
while they're trying to read or
something
so you know i can't even imagine that's
like my worst nightmare oh my god
i i would not be set up for that
lifestyle
well there's like a little rule that you
know that like me is a shower after so
that they're not
you know like sucking another girl's
juices off my dick and stuff like that
you know
mm-hmm but i mean like
you have to uh you know made it work and
ended yeah
he was like actually paying the girl the
only thing i paid for is the the rent of
the house because i was gonna
have this place anyways and originally
it was just me and my
main brazilian chicken here and it you
know so
do you ever want to get married um i
don't think so
uh why um i'm not happy
in a monogamous relationship i've tried
it a bunch of times
and it's it's become as my game skills
have progressed it's become even harder
because it's it's hard to like turn the
switch off
um like i interviewed paul janka and he
was like a famous
new york city day game pickup artist he
dropped out of the game at like 200
count
or 250 count he was harvard physics
background
uh i respect him a lot as well and we
found a bunch of overlap in what we were
doing
in terms of methodology and he said his
close rates about 10
of his phone numbers as well which
matches mine but he said he had to like
actively kill a bunch of parts of
himself because it was hard for him to
be around an attractive girl without
like salivating
and not literally but you know like when
you know what to do know what to say
know how to move everything through the
process
like it's a good example like in puerto
rico i had this full package
that what to me it was like a 10 extra
internally and she was like a lingerie
model and she was like on billboards and
[ __ ] in san juan
and like half italian half puerto rican
like super
hot super cool chick and i deleted my
tinder
stopped going out uh like blocked all
the girls i was actively talking to
dropped my whole rotation um you know it
was like a cold approach pickup i
picked up off the street um it was like
a night it was like a block
party type thing but i approached her
and then i basically night game setting
on the street
and um long story short
like i ended up like having a hot uber
driver i banged
her a hot girl near me on the plane i
banged her like on a plane ride
um my chick couldn't come to like a
holiday party in my building and i had
like a threesome with two other girls in
the building
that had like boyfriends and it yeah and
i was like actively really trying and
it's you know it sounds like like almost
like
you know almost sucks to you know i got
almost like i'm like
trying to brag about it but i was
literally trying to like not
not do anything bad but it's just hard
like because
you can't completely avoid attractive
women and sometimes and sometimes you
have to talk to them
like would you and would you ever be oh
sorry go ahead god
i was going to say like it's just like
you
you just take over on instinct and it
just
it and and i wouldn't want it in those
situations i
i wouldn't want to not do it either and
because you get like this whole rush of
like
the game is fun and like getting the hot
girl and getting the hot stranger to
fall for you is fun so
to me it's like if a guy who like became
a chess grandmaster and then he's like
okay i'm putting away the chess board
and never playing again
that's what that's what marriage would
be like to me
would you ever like um because some guys
have arrangements where they're married
and they have like they have one like
maine wife but she knows that he
you know goes and hooks up with other
girls would that be ever be something
you'd want to do
um yes i mean but then we're just
talking about like stupid labels i mean
you can have
all the the rich emotional fulfillment
of a girlfriend or a wife without
the stupid label right the stupid label
just introduces a whole bunch of
problems
and it makes it like a contract where
the man loses in most cases in the
states
um but i mean yeah i see nothing wrong
with that as long
i just don't like the like just pure
monogamy feels
suffocating to me and just being with
one woman
um is i'm just not ultimately fulfilled
with that and that's nothing
against any girl personally and i've had
like a lot of really awesome girlfriends
i have an awesome one now
and they hate hearing that that they're
like not enough but it's
i i just you know i've always like i've
lived all around the world
i like like changing things up and stuff
like that and to to be
um set with just one body type forever
one or one
personality like people's personalities
get predictable
and it makes things more fulfilling with
the main girl
when she's contrasting to other girls
bodies and personalities
and sex and stuff like that because then
it's not just the same it's like you
were to eat the same meal every day
versus a variety of things i guess i
don't know so
and plus it's not natural that's the
other big thing is i've
i've done the research on that stuff and
and i used to read a ton of neuroscience
books and they said there's a part of
our brain responsible for monogamy
and humans don't have it definitively
and then there's a species of monkeys
that have it and they only always have
one mate
and when they tinker with that part of
the brain it goes around and starts
uh sleeping with everyone but what they
found with humans we're
meant to have like one main partner and
a bunch of side partners pretty much
what a rotation is
and you know and it's like basically
what a tribe what's happening in a tribe
as well
and officially only five percent of
mammals are monogamous
so i think the reason for the high
divorce rates and the the amount of
cheating and stuff like that
it's due to the church and the state
having pushed
this institution that's not natural at
all and you can watch
i like reference in this example you can
look at like a 70 year old man
who's been married for 50 years and is
in love and all this
with his wife and he's still gonna like
get turned on or like turn and look at
like the hot 19 year old
in a little outfit and that doesn't mean
he doesn't love his wife
it just means he has biological
circuitry to be attracted to something
like that and
and i think that he'd like to [ __ ] the
girl if he could
and i think that a lifetime of like
suppressing this urge to [ __ ] attractive
women
because you're now married and and guys
getting these positions i've talked to
countless clients
or friends or whatever well you know my
wife isn't as pretty as she used to be
and she's gotten really [ __ ] and
and i can't really do much about it and
if i i want to get divorced but then i
would maybe lose
rights to the you know some of the
custody to the kids
and i'd maybe lose my house and i don't
want to lose half my [ __ ]
and so i'm just gonna stay miserable and
that's how a lot of people are living
their lives
and to me to me that sounds horrible
well it's interesting because that's a
little bit red pill what you're talking
about right now with like um what you
said with the no
like not getting married because
partially because of you're going to
lose most times in the state
lead states legally there's a lot of
guys in the red pill that don't believe
in marriage as well
so i was curious if you guys just had a
very like a similar
and they also like believe in rotations
a lot of them like if you listen to
myron talk like he believes in rotations
too
but a lot of them got married right you
know like rollo is married
donovan sharp is married um you know
i i think like ryan stone i think he's
officially married now too but
these girls look at their wives they're
all below average yeah
and they're preaching you know never
i think donovan preaches like never get
married only
be with very attractive women and they
talk about not with getting
not knocking with women over the wall
but in secret
they married below average over the wall
women
and those women run the show too in the
sense of like calling the shots in their
open ship i know that for a fact too
from guys that are
like anthony johnson who's friends with
or used to be friends with donovan
um said that like she calls all the
shots as well so
these guys are like full hypocrites at
the very least uh doing the direct
opposite of all these things they're
preaching on camera
at least at least i have like the three
girls in the house and like show endless
receipts i'm like very open about my
lifestyle here
and i don't even see myself in the same
category as these dating coaches
because none of them are able to do that
or show that it doesn't mean they need
to live with multiple girls but
if they can't even show that they've
gotten hot girls and i can show
you know like hundreds of pictures like
that you know what
what good is their advice or that you
know that that's what i mean about the
quality control a lot of these guys have
never even shown one girl
yeah well i i like the red pill because
i like a lot of their self-improvement
stuff
and i think they do like there's certain
truths about women that they
they show um like the being too nice
type of thing i just think
they're so they haven't really found
like the solution a lot of times of how
to really like get
girls yeah and that's that's why i liked
your system a little better because
just in terms of like listening to how
you
like your whole system and i don't know
all of it because i obviously wouldn't
have a reason to buy your course
um as a female but just like the stuff
that you have shown made a lot of sense
to me as a girl
um like i was like yeah like i could see
that working on me
like yeah and it's interesting too
because
a lot of the like strategy elements were
formed through induction
through just like mass data and testing
um
but then as like independent
confirmation like like you said that i
would have had lots of girls tell me
like once they see some of the inner
workings or even when i just have them
explain to me like what's a woman
thinking on a date or this and that it
lines up perfectly with my stuff
um because i wish i would have went to
women a lot sooner to talk to them about
these things than trying to just
do it from the other side through
induction because
women know obviously more than any guy
does
about what it is that they're attracted
to and stuff like that although they
don't always report it
the way that it is you know like women
always think they want a nice guy in the
and the bad boys are [ __ ] and this
and that but they're drawn to
you know guys that they can't figure out
if they like them or not and
you know kind of more like the guys that
don't give a [ __ ] and convey that
congruently
um so then one last one last question
um what do you think of hypergamy has
any girl left you for a higher value guy
um that's it's definitely a real thing
um so for those of you guys that don't
know it's it's basically just like girls
trading up right trading up and
in value or or uh status or money it can
apply to any category right if the girl
is like a better guy than you yeah it's
what the girl values so like
um like i have friends that value like a
guy's relationship with god
so to speak so if you go to like a
church there's like a hierarchy of like
what guys seem to have the best
relationship with god
could be money it could be status it
just depends on the girl
yeah so i i've never formally had a
girlfriend break up with me i was always
one that ended it
although i did have a girl cheat on me
in miami that was a girlfriend
and i still ended up but she was uh
it was largely my fault in a sense like
i met her in san diego
we moved to miami together um she
dropped out of college moved miami with
me she had like no money i was paying
for the apartment
and she's like i want to contribute she
was really hot so didn't want to
contribute to the
expenses and stuff of that so she got a
job as a stripper
that was like my idea too i was like
this would be cool and so she started
working at 11
in miami it's like a 24 hour strip club
and
there's a lot of like drugs and just
like skeevy underworld type [ __ ] going
on there
and so she started she picked up like i
i think she was
using various drugs behind my back and
like
and we were having these different
arguments because she was like abusing
substances and this and that
and then uh it kind of culminated where
we got in like a big fight and then
and then some like drug dealer dude like
gave her a bunch of drugs and then she
like cheated on me while she was all
[ __ ] up on drugs
and i like [ __ ] i i didn't i didn't find
out for sure but i
i i like inferred that that's probably
what happened
and so i just like moved out of that
apartment and left and
i never got back with that chick so i
got i don't think she was really like
that wasn't a situation where she was
like
trading up because she ended up dating
the guy after
and they started they started like
actually making porn together and [ __ ]
wow it's like a weird wow
yeah because she had been like camming
she was like camming also on the side
and then
and then she just decided it would be a
good idea for them to like
start [ __ ] together on the on the cam
shows
um so i was like we have very different
circles i don't know
i actually dated a lot of strippers i
think the majority of my girlfriends
were
stripper two of them let's see three of
them became strippers after
we started dating and then um
and then a bunch of the other ones were
strippers at the time of meeting them
but yeah those always end in flames but
it's cool because it's like
you know higher highs lower lows and
strippers are pretty cool chicks and
stuff like that
but yeah the the current girl is an
engineer
but she gets all this flack like modern
like
the guy that i'm suing my life dating
was trying to say that
oh she's she's a prostitute and
you know well and i actually like showed
like um
a commercial commercial a news report
where she's like being interviewed and
like giving like technical specs about
the bridge with like her engineering
uniform and her name polishes
this is stupid these guys like make such
low blows
like like trying to you know just claim
like fully fabricated things
but so that's why uh you know taking
legal action in this case
um with that situation but
yeah i mean just to to kind of like sum
up the whole in the whole industry
it's just kind of like a whole load of
[ __ ] i i look at it as
um it's just a whole bunch of
impressionable young men
getting misled and tricked on a massive
scale
by sometimes charismatic sometimes not
cult leaders that are just spewing
all kinds of fake support for their
so-called
skills or their so-called
accomplishments and
and the vast majority like you know
when and i've shown in like 40 different
videos
have no real credentials have no real
skills or very minimal
shitty skills that's the thing like if
you look at all these like major gurus
right
i think that one video i did about their
girls says a lot even though it seems
like a pot shot or whatever
if this is the end result of the
culmination
of his his time in the game as a guru
what do you think the rest of the girls
looked like
if he's like he's like checking out of
the game and marrying a three or four
out of ten
that you know that that's like 40
something um
how do you think he did the rest of the
time in the game and then these guys are
going oh yeah like in my 20s my 30s it
was just
nines and tens this and that no it
wasn't
there probably weren't even sevens you
know there probably wasn't many girls of
any kind at all
that's the thing that's like the sad
truth here and
and a lot of these guys that see these
videos of mine
their whole reality is kind of
shattering because they thought this guy
was like a superhero
and you know it happened to me too i
mean i i thought tyler durden was like
the god of pickup because that's how he
makes himself out to be
and i took a program with him and
realized my game was
was light years beyond his and then it
was all a [ __ ] lie and i caught him
in countless lives on top of it and
and then the whole house of cards fell
down but a lot of guys are still
drinking that kool-aid
and and not just with him but with a
whole bunch of other guys
that that turn out to you know
literally you know like rolo tomasi for
instance
you know like he is he is not getting
girls i don't
like yeah of course not like he he's
he's like
far worse off than like the average guy
that knows nothing about any of this
stuff
and the fact you know but he's making
lots of money off it and he pushes these
other guys that are that are full
scammers and i think he knows that a
bunch of these other guys
it's very obvious and i put out all the
proof and i know that they've seen those
videos
very obvious a lot of these guys have no
credentials or they're full on scamming
but they promote his book you know so
that's the thing is they stick together
they can all
cross promote each other and cross rep
each other and i was kind of this
outsider that came in
and said hey these guys [ __ ] suck
number one they're full of [ __ ]
and like look at the facts that's it's
not just my opinion
it's not that's the thing like people
get pissed at me and they backlash at me
when i present facts about these guys
wives or
about these guys um you know not having
any real credentials
or when i find out like a guy's laycount
being really low and expose that
there was one coach that um was that
was he was a popular coach too it came
out that he had a late count of like
eight girls
and it was all from tinder and he was
teaching cold approach
as part of his curriculum and he'd never
even banned one girl from cold approach
and i got him off the scene this was
years back but
he was living in england and i waited
until
i waited until it was like 4 a.m in
england and put this whole like
big post out showing like screen you
know stuff of him basically admitting it
and everyone was mind blown but that's
the thing is is that uh
you know if some random guy off the
street said he's banged a thousand girls
um versus like myself who's actually
done it who's to know the difference
that's why i have a video
that's my proof for bang over a thousand
girls where i show
like 300 of them post on instagram in
like you know
hook up touch wait not like breaking
laws or anything but where
like in a bedroom situation the girl's
face is blocked
um all kinds of other different
evidence to prove
would you ever go on fresh and fit and
debate them
uh yeah for sure they would never have
me on there they haven't even responded
to one of the videos i made
everyone was like oh they clap back at
everyone but everything i've said is
factual
that's the thing like i'm very careful
not to slander anyone
um i i say stuff that i've like
independently
found out to be true and that's why they
haven't clapped back there's nothing to
come back at where they're going to deny
facts
i've shown that i've shown the evidence
for these things
you know so yeah i'm not afraid i wanted
anyone about anything um
ever really that's the thing i i love
for any of these guys that i roast
i would love it's basically like what
coffeezilla does and
i don't announce this enough but it you
know for anyone out there
that would like to you know vindicate
themselves and and
you know i'm not going to attack these
guys if they're not pieces of [ __ ]
ripping people off
and and lying and scamming you know if
if they're like
putting out a good system and they're
not lying about their [ __ ]
and they're not [ __ ] guys over and
i'm not going to attack them
so you know and that's why they would
never get on camera with me because it
would make them look far worse
because i would just trash them further
but yeah
if you i don't know if you i know but
you really know those guys
i don't know if you know those guys but
i would if you want to facilitate what
anybody does
what are they going to say i i showed
that that they have no
they i showed myron uh his email did you
see the video
yeah i saw that he emailed me for
coaching two years ago and he used to
hit me up on whatsapp and try to get a
discount
for a boot camp and he admitted it's
only banging between four and eight
range
on camera he says only nines and tens
but four and eight range is not
inclusive with nines and tens it also
includes fours
yeah um no i'm actually trying to get on
their podcast in the next couple weeks
because i'm going to miami
so um i'll definitely mention it when i
go because i would love to see that i
think it'd be really interesting
that's that's the thing though what are
they you know what are they gonna say
like like those things are all real
like they're and i have a bunch more
evidence having them released
they're paying multiple girls there's a
whole [ __ ]
there's a whole it's it goes very deep
and
there's a new video today that actually
came out that a bunch of people sent to
me there's some
uh instagram model i guess that went on
youtube
on instagram like as a story or
a live or something and said that they
like um
sexually assaulted her allegedly or
something like this or
uh there's a whole nother [ __ ] can of
worms but to me those guys are like
it's like a full-on clown show um
you know it's it's really sad what
they've done um
yeah i think they work hard you can tell
that they like they're in the studio
every night
um i like their self-improvement stuff i
just don't see their like tips for
girls being overly effective um
that's kind of the way i see fresh and
fit is like i see you as more of like an
actual
expert with the solution where they're
just kind of trying to fake it till they
make it
exactly yeah and they even they made
like some little slip-ups here and there
where they had like
girls um critique like practice
instagram live
and they're all like this is crap you
know it's just him trying to be cool
like posing next to super cars and and
planes and stuff
and they're like this is cheesy this is
cringe and and
and then fresh is like let's let's have
them look at myrons
and myron's like no no absolutely not
absolutely not and i did a video on this
and then he says like oh but it's but
it's not because i i'm worried about
them looking at us because we're like
almost out of time we got that thing
you know but it's like just he knew they
would [ __ ] tear him apart too
because that's like that's that's like
the big satisfaction that i get is that
no matter how many guys they trick they
know
that they suck with pics like rsc tyler
like fresh and fit
they know it's all fake they know and so
you know
let them have an army of people
believing their lies
and today hot girls don't want anything
to do with them and to me that that's
the best part
because you know they they can they can
say what they
they can say anything and they can be be
the cool guys in quotes all
day long but they go to bed at night
knowing they're [ __ ] losers
and i think that's [ __ ] hilarious
where can people find you
on social media and where can they find
your courses do you have any like
specials going on
um i do actually have a 50 off my
texting product
happening right now that's uh
it's sex leadmachine.com 50 off sale
um is there a way you can i know you can
do like a banner and
do you know how to do like a banner up
on the screen
if you go to my if you go to my channel
it's it's advertised on my channel
oh yeah i can i can do that hold on let
me pull it up on the screen
it's just on your youtube channel
because i can choose yeah just put my
channel name they can see there's a sale
on there
but basically the the premier course
that i run is an eight week mentorship
program
um week one is online game weeks two and
three is night game
week four is day game week five is
texting week six
is here we got the [ __ ] screen over
here
share screen okay week six is
um oh
uh john anthony here yeah that flashbail
to my texting product
it's like the second video there we go
up down a little bit yeah third one over
this one yeah that has a
uh a link in the description oh there it
is right there okay
oh you can see it on the screen actually
if you go up back up to the video
okay okay there we go yeah it's
sexymachine.com
50 off sale that's that's my texting
product that basically
tells you every control path to go from
a match to a phone number a phone number
to a date
and then how to run your date and how to
close your date um so there's that and
then the thing under my face here
platinumdatingsystem.com that's the
eight week mentorship
it's basically online game week one
night game weeks two and three day game
week four texting week five how to run
your dates week six
how to close the house week seven and
week eight um
is retention keeping the girl around
after you after you hook up
and um guys get extremely extremely good
usually by week two or three most guys
schedules are fully packed
out with dates and that and then you can
repeat that for a lifetime
it's meant to be a permanent and final
solution um but at
plymouthdatingsystems.com you can jump
on a free 30-minute call and we go over
all the details with you and it's all
customized based on where the guy's at
in the game where his bottlenecks are
and what his goals are because some guys
want to get
a girlfriend or a wife and someone and
just
run through a lot of girls but but most
guys um end up getting like
five to ten girls a month through that
program and and then they can go on and
do 50 200 girls a year
and and the reason for that is i
literally have them get a pro photo
shoot
i have a team of girls that picks the
top five photos we apply aesthetic
upgrades to those photos
i write their bio for them now they're
getting a good quantity in quality of
matches
they plug into my scripts gives phone
numbers from the matches plug into
the texting scripts you get dates from
the
phone numbers and so even virgins that
come through
we just had a virgin from the uk that
he had taken like five other dating
courses nobody got him laid nobody was
even really getting dates
he had seven dates on week two um he got
his first close on day four of the
program and he ended up with eight girls
total by the
end of the eight weeks thing one week at
three but on average about a girl a week
this is a guy that had failed for like a
decade with a whole bunch of other
courses and that's
was very common almost every guy that
comes to me i was watching this guy and
this guy and this guy and i took this
boot camp and bought this product and i
suck
that's i've heard that story thousands
of times and then
by week two or week three hey i don't
have enough time to go on all these
dates
right and then we add in the cold
approach in weeks two through four
and it's it's now they're on the other
side and now they're able to
build rotation that guy built like a
four girl rotation too in the program
so once guys know how to do things
properly that's like
90 of the battle like mindset is
important as well but
um too many guys leave out all the how
leave out all the strategy all the
tactics
that that's that's what i provide in
full detail so i give guys like the full
optimized blueprint of exactly what to
do with every step of the way
but i also make it as simple as possible
so
it you know it removes all the fluff all
the bs
and it just gives guys a clear uh
game plan so that that they're not you
know they're not able to [ __ ] it up
really it's it's
it's really hard to [ __ ] it up imagine
you imagine any random guy watching here
if you were to um get your pro pictures
the next thing that you would
doing is going on a lot of dates because
the tech scripts set up all the dates
for you
and it's a matter of showing you how to
run the dates properly and close the
dates but
um yeah i won't i won't go online about
that planetary assistant.com for those
interested
um did you have any other um
final you know did you wanna give any
final thoughts on anything else
um no i think we're okay for today but
i'm definitely
gonna have you on again and hopefully
you can come back on the channel
yeah sure yeah yeah it was awesome
and just so you guys know um he has rece
i know a lot of people
because they don't know you so they're
they're going to question your
credibility he has receipts of all this
stuff that's what made me look at his
channel
his his main girlfriend all the girls in
his house they're all stunning like
they're beautiful
and he has like people on this channel
all the time that
talk about how much this program helps
them so if you guys want to check it out
go to his channel he literally has
all the receipts i have i have a video
too that i'm really
proud of i already mentioned that um
it's basically it's called my proof for
bang
a thousand girls and i made that just
because like when people hear the
numbers so high like now it's 1384.
um when they hear that number so high
they immediately think [ __ ]
right which in most cases when guys
claim that it is but i've kept exact
track the whole way through anyone that
knows me personally knows i take the the
number extremely seriously just because
i feel like it's all that a guy has to
to go on in terms of his credibility in
the industry
so i've been reporting it steadily since
i hit 100 back on the forums
um i say it and i'm almost every video
with the
if you look back at my other videos so i
hit 777
like girl 777 and i'm wearing like a
casino slot shirt with like triple
sevens you know there's all these little
stupid things
um that and that's how i made the chart
because because i was always saying the
count all the way through
and when you plot it surprise surprise
it's like a smooth exponential
which is which is really fascinating and
you know from it from an evolutionary
optimization standpoint it makes sense
that's the same way that like technology
progresses and stuff like that
and obviously there's there's asymptotes
and limits there's only
i remember rsd jeffy told me back when i
worked for rsd for a few months in 2012
he said there's physical and say
physical and temp
temporal limits to how much you can [ __ ]
in a day or something like that
so you know but like i have a guy just
real quick i have a guy in the in the
program right now that's a 300 late
count
student that started at 300 late count
and he's
added a whole bunch more value but but
implementing all my stuff he just had 25
dates set
in a weekend like two weekends ago he
only went on nine of them
but that shows you kind of the level you
can take this stuff to
um most people can't fathom 25 i don't
think i've ever even had that many set
in the weekend
25
but when you're when you're
systematizing this
it all the the result it's like a
machine that it just puts out you know
when it
if if you're like just just real fast
like it through the top through the
funnel thing like basically if you're
getting like 15 to 20 leads a week
from online game night game and day game
my texting will set up the dates
and then you just go on the dates and
you execute the dates and we get guys
fixing their problems so that they're
bringing home most of their dates now we
work on the closing at the house
and then we get them closing most dates
and then we work on the retention
and now they're retaining most girls
they want to retain and then literally
they can just repeat that forever
it's because they know how to move girls
through from level level but the reason
why most guys
uh get very shitty results and don't
have much of a chance
is because they have compounding
bottlenecks the whole way through
so they'll do the top wrong and get not
many phone numbers they'll text strong
not many dates run the dates are on not
many girls back home
and if they get a close once in a while
it's typically not the consistency of
the quality that they want not even
close
so that's that's really where i come in
is to to make the whole thing very
smooth and you know from working in
sales
if you have like bottlenecks in the
sales funnel it's very difficult to get
close prospects through to the end right
but when you open up the whole thing
very wide and you put some volume in at
the top
it's it just becomes you know like a
little closing machine like you can move
to a new city
and build a new rotation of four to six
girls in about one to two months
so that's the that's the benefit of it
and then you can just relax enjoy the
rotation you don't have to just keep
grinding it out so well and guys when
they um
the benefit of having more girls and not
just necessarily like getting rid of
them is you don't
often know what's going on in a girl's
life so sometimes she'll reject
you but it has nothing to do with you
like maybe she's not over her ex
maybe she's like talking to someone else
right now that she's more interested in
um and i think that's why i like your
approach is because
you take that stuff into account and you
don't take it so personal
yeah yeah i could say like that's the
thing i could say anything on the
channel but i give guys the real stats
and that's why it's frustrating because
the
the people that are lying and faking say
like oh you can get rid of rejection
completely you can stop flaking
completely no you can't
on either of those because there's thing
are you telling me a girl is never going
to have anything come up in her schedule
where she has to change plans and cancel
that's of course that's not true
right or there's never going to be a
girl you talk to that has a boyfriend or
a husband or is in a bad mood or
you know just generally doesn't want to
talk to anyone right then so
rather than looking taking every
rejection or flake personally
you look at it as part of the game it's
the same thing in sales like you can't
cold call or knock doors and and get 100
positive receptions you're going to
have people slamming the door and
telling you to [ __ ] off it doesn't
matter if you're the best salesman in
the world that will happen
so i i it's important for guys to be
realistic
and yeah 10 close rate doesn't seem like
that much
but it you know it can come out to one
to two new girls a week which is more
than enough for anyone
so when the dust settles you know it's
it's still
you have more girls you can handle but
those are the those are the real stats
and the real facts and i think guys
should know that at a high level
that's what's happening and so they can
aspire to to try to
you know get a close-up but also so they
don't get demoralized
when they get a negative reaction and
i've ran experiments where
when i get rejected i'm not with an
advanced friend i'll send him in on the
same girl
or vice versa if he gets rejected i'll
go in and nine times out of ten it's the
same reaction
from that girl which means you know
there's just girls that have boyfriends
and husbands
there's that don't want to cheat there's
girls in a bad mood maybe you're not her
type for whatever reason
maybe she's you know just standoffish or
she got approached too much that night
there's so many variables outside of
your control for a girl to reject a guy
even
maybe even a harsh rejection in the guy
to think oh that's because i suck
or own occasion she reacted to this now
i must suck
that's the wrong way to do it right so
that's why i tell guys
your value should think of your value at
100 out of 100 never changes
there's a brick wall here and then uh
external event that should be from this
side external events
uh can't pass through that wall really
like so negative reactions rejections
etc
don't impact your value being out of
100. so i firmly disagree with the idea
of like state or like warming up when
you get to the club you should always
think of yourself at 100 100 you can
bring your a game at any any time any
place that doesn't mean you'll get every
girl
but that's the best mindset to bring
forward because otherwise you're
handicapping yourself
if you think like oh i'm in the club and
i'm not warmed up yet
or you know i just hit five rejections
in a row or ten rejections in a row
therefore like i'm gonna keep getting
rejected that that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
and the guy comes in like huh hello okay
look see she rejected me but it's
because he went in
like defeatist and all that stuff so and
that goes back to where you're talking
about if the guy's hung up on being
short or
ethnic or whatever he's he's pretty much
rejecting himself in a lot of cases
there's going to be girls that like him
still but he just has a negative
attitude about it
yeah so well thank you so much for
coming on this was such a fun
conversation yeah i appreciate you
having me on and yeah did you
what was your what was your impression
of how i acted
here different than what you thought it
would be from the videos because people
usually think i'm going to be like some
big [ __ ]
um no you kind of seem like the videos
to be honest i felt like the same vibe
i don't think you're an [ __ ] from the
videos um i think you're just
blunt and most especially females like i
don't think most girls can have like
conversations like this and not get
emotional i don't know why
i'm just built different i guess
we have a lot of people like because in
my video like in the roast videos or
exposed videos i'll be like swearing and
like getting all
you know like worked up and aggressive
and then in real life i'm actually
really chill so then people are always
like
oh i thought you're going to be this
huge [ __ ] when we talked but
yeah i appreciate you having me on um
cool uh yeah let me know about coming
back i'll have you on my channel at some
point soon too i'm trying to do more
more people on my channel as well yeah
no that'd be super fun
um and thanks for watching yeah what is
like
you said like you have um what's like
the major
uh focus of your channel it's not
related to game per se
directly or um honestly i kind of just
fell into like red pill and pickup
so i'm just like reacting to different
like
like problems that men go through and
like pick up and
everything just from the girl's point of
view i don't consider myself like an
expert at any of this stuff
i'm just like watching and being
entertained and people watch me
watch any reactions
yeah i've been meaning to do more
reaction videos too i think it's super
fun
yeah give it your input and then it can
turn into like something funny or crazy
who who's like your favorite red pill
guy oh you said ams right
no um i don't
i like kevin samuels actually because
he's like the first
guy that i felt like was honest to women
so um like for example he what he does
is he rates girls as like you're either
out like a one to ten they ask them to
rate themselves
and you can't say seven so that
automatically forces girls to either
like
say that i'm closer to like average like
six five or i'm like model status aids
does that make sense
yeah like hot or not basically yeah and
so um but then he talks about like ways
you can like
improve like for example like losing
weight or being more feminine
um he talks about getting rid of the
[ __ ] attitude like some of the stuff
that you talked about
yeah and like most girls dating advice
is just
you're perfect how you are big is
beautiful you know like it's not real
and that like with the way he described
it just made me like oh
like that stuff i can actually like i
can hire a personal trainer like i can
dress more feminine like that's stuff i
can do to like improve myself
yeah and yeah and what's interesting is
like i i have a video
um about the differences between eastern
and western women in general from my
experiences like living in
in poland and ukraine and some of these
other countries
and i found that in general like the
eastern european girls and a lot of the
south american girls too
in brazil now are just more feminine
more elegant play less games
they're more respectful there's less of
like a power struggle there's less of
like them putting themselves
on some big you know pedestal or
something like this
um and i think american girls used to be
like that and
yeah i'm not trying to stereotype all
women in america but in general
in western cultures like they it used to
be more like how i'm describing that it
is in eastern europe currently
and there's a lot of like things that
happen with culture and media and all
these things
i have friends that have written books
on this but you know like like
men in america are becoming increasingly
more feminine women in america are
becoming
increasingly more masculine and it's
almost like switching in a lot of cases
where you have these guys
i guess that's why they're where the
term simp and other things apply
or the guys are just like full spineless
pushovers
and you know like like the the new
generations like
there was no uh working with your hands
or like
any heart rate hardships or great wars
anything like that and so a lot of
people are very soft
and i think it's i think a lot of guys
have lost their their edge
you know so to speak and and that's like
[ __ ] repellent
when you're in that state well and from
a girl's point of view i think we're
just given like
bad dating advice like i don't think
we're given honest
dating advice like go for a guy in your
league
you know because most girls don't even
know their league because
like most guys that are eights nines and
tens will still hook up with an average
girl
yeah yeah yeah i think it's i think it's
interesting when you see those
uh analyses done where it's like the hot
guy will or the high value guy will
well bang um you know like i guess like
a girl
maybe like a six five or seven sometimes
and then as she like starts to lose her
looks a little more
um now she can only like rope in like
some like loser guy
to be like the provider you know stuff
but then she'll still try to cheat with
the
high value guys on the side and
eventually the high value guys don't
even want to bang her
oh see that's very red pill like what
you're saying right now that's very red
pill
yeah i mean the the thing is is like you
know
some of these are just like straight
objective intuitive facts
i think when we get to the point of like
you need to
uh resent women or be confrontational or
they know how
soccer that's when it takes it too far
yeah
it's it's definitely you know in in
terms of like you know like simple
economic principles of like supply and
demand
and like uh you know a woman a woman's
value and how many
um other options the guys have and this
kind of stuff all those things that
naturally apply but
for everything i've gathered from the
red pill is it's it's a bunch of
fake gurus spouting off uh
just a lot of rhetoric and theoretical
things
and it's still not giving you guys a
strategy like in the pickup world
guys don't have a strategy but they're
not like
actively confrontational and resentful
towards women
and then like makes it one step worse
where now they have no strategy but
they're resentful and confrontational
and almost hate women
or actively do hate women and then
blackpill says give up
and like you're [ __ ] no and that's why
i say i really
like parts of red pill like i genuinely
do like parts of red pill i just don't
think they always have the solution
and what i liked about you was that i
felt like you offered more of a solution
when it comes to like getting laid
or even getting in a relationship with a
quality girl
like you you give people strategies of
how to do it and you
have like measured results that everyone
can see on the internet
so yeah that's like that's my opinion on
like red pill
and i think black pill is just like mad
at red pill because red pill acts like
if a guy has
like gets a lot of money and um
like get a lot of money goes to the gym
then all of a sudden he's going to get
girls and black pill just says
well what if you're going to do this
yeah i
i have i've had tons of rich clients
with no results i've had tons of famous
clients with no results
i've had tons of uh chat clients and no
results i have a guy right now
that's like jack tall tattoos three lay
count
and he's still [ __ ] up like like even
with proper strategy
he's like he's having like three four
hour dates he's like too nervous to
make moves and this and that he's
getting like hugs goodbye you know weird
[ __ ] like that
but but all his friends think that he
would just be like a natural lady killer
just based on
what he has going on yeah you guys will
be surprised i i get
without like giving anyone's anonymity i
get i get some of the top poker players
in the world
i get um like retired like rock stars
i've gotten like and they're just lonely
they're like i had one guy recently we
did a video call from his mansion in
vegas
and he was on like he was pretty famous
for a bunch of stuff he was on ellen and
howard's turn all this [ __ ] and he's
like
i haven't been late in a year i'm about
to turn 50 and spend my birthday alone
it's like i still don't have this
[ __ ] game figured out
or like or the guys like uh you know
like a super wealthy
uh businessman and has accomplished like
far more than anyone ever has and he's
in an unhappy marriage
and he's worried about ending the
marriage and you know being too old and
not knowing how to get back in the game
and being lonely and all this stuff
so yeah looks looks and money and status
definitely do not fix things or physique
um
i i like i said i think without without
the strategy
i think if i were to make a pie chart
the strategy
the strategy and the tactics would be
the the giant part of the equation
um and you know with the caveat that
it can't you know i had like a client
that was like
literally deformed from an accident and
that was we couldn't
you know we couldn't get him results but
those are extreme circumstances
you know most people aren't most people
aren't deformed and stuff like that
um i haven't i even got a guy in a
wheelchair
to take girls home multiple times on a
program in london which i have a review
on my channel about
um and that and i thought it was going
to go like a nightmare
but the girls were actually uh very
receptive because they thought he needed
help usually when he
when he would approach them you can't
really tell a guy in a wheelchair to
[ __ ] off but
but you just make the best of what you
have to work with on his tinder he said
i prefer girl on top not because i'm in
a wheelchair but because i'm lazy you
know
he was actually like yeah he was a
really cool kid he just had cerebral
palsy but
he was he was texting me the second out
of the program he was in a stripper's
bed
he's like what do i do next she just
lifted me from my chair into the bed
he's like texting me you know and that's
why i love my job it's
my old business partner used to say hey
hey we're [ __ ] with evolution
but you know it kind of begs the
question if if
i'm able to get lots of guys that
traditionally shouldn't be getting girls
by
by society standards and what does that
say i think society's standards about
what you need to get girls is wrong
well and the one thing i actually
respect on some level because i'm not
really into the whole
like i would never be in a situation
with multiple like girls i would never
like that's just not something i would
do or really push but i respect that
you're like up front with the girls and
you don't
tell them it's something it's not which
i think
a lot of um guys will tell like that's
what they want to do but instead of
being upfront with a girl
they just like do it and then she finds
out yeah well
to be fair that's what i did originally
with my main girl in brazil because
originally like we were like on the
surface monogamous boyfriend girlfriend
and i was those teen girls on the side
and then you know she would catch me
i'll be careful but she but she would
like find a girl's hair an earring or
stupid [ __ ] like that or or like come
home early then one time she like caught
me with a girl and that caused like
plenty of big fights
um but that's what i mean with the
growing pains
i i had to and she cares on me a lot
and she knows i'm not happy with pure
monogamy even though she would prefer
that
she knows that it's it's not like in the
cards for me
so she you know basically
i don't want to say tolerates it because
she actually really enjoys it now but in
the beginning
with anything it's you know like when i
when i started becoming more outgoing
and
when people like make big adjustments in
life when i when i blast away one of
these fake gurus
and guys are left kind of like
staggering after you get through that
kind of initial shock period and you
kind of acclimate
and you're on the other side that's when
things get really exciting
so like with my philosophical views they
led me down a path where i
pretty much rejected religion and and
ultimate meaning in life and
even even in a basis for morality
objectively
when you look into the science and stuff
behind and then you're kind of left
with the existential problem where you
think okay what's the point of doing
anything
and it becomes depressive
potentially at first but as i like
explored more like frederick nietzsche
you can turn it into an empowerment
model where you
you know look at yourself as coming out
of the the metaphorical plato's cave and
now you can
create your own values and you can
create your own purpose
and now you're like set free in a sense
i go on camera on youtube i say and do
whatever the [ __ ] i want right and
sometimes there's consequences but it
every day can be like a an adventure and
you can
um we're like playing outside of the
traditional bounds and traditional rules
so it the sky is a limit like we we're
we're always
and i'm an analyzer and optimizer so as
new stuff comes in
we adjust things accordingly i think
what might be next is that we get an
even bigger place
like random mansion because there's a
few other side girls
that want to live with us as well and so
i might end up with like six or seven of
these girls
in a big mansion and at that point i was
thinking about getting like a film crew
in there or something like that and
maybe even trying to do like a
show i meant people would watch that
um i was gonna ask do you want kids
because that's the one
um it seems like that would be a tough
environment for like kids to grow up in
yeah um i don't think so i think that um
i guess that's another thing that people
just kind of get shuffled into
when i've weighed the pros and cons
extensively i think there's just far too
many cons and deal breaker cons at that
i think that everyone have talked to the
house kids it becomes your number one
priority so that limits your
your freedom and you know even ability
to travel and
move around and stuff but also if you
look at like the life cycle of a child
in the first few years it's basically
the equivalent of an animal
and you know from the sense of just you
know not to
sound like a dick just looking at it
like pretty logically it's basically
they call them an animal then it's kind
of like
very stupid and naive and um
uh it turns into like a rebellious phase
where it like hates you and eventually
you guys like come to
come to terms later on in life and and
reconcile them
the whole thing is kind of strange so
um and plus i'm a big proponent of like
the technological singularity
with artificial intelligence surpassing
human intelligence and i think that's
in the near future and i think there's
going to be a lot of incredible paradigm
shifts
in the next five to ten years where
traditional familiar units will
not be what they once were and people
will be spending most their time in
in virtual worlds um even more virtual
than now like
like akin to like the matrix and stuff
like this with nanotechnology
so this but the short answer is is most
likely not although the girls
do want and if there is a long-term
future i could see them
potentially co-raising a child but
well you know well it's interesting
it's interesting you say that because um
i don't know if you you probably haven't
seen my channel at all
i looked a little bit have you seen like
the house tour and stuff
i saw i saw it come up but i didn't
watch it but that made me think that it
was like a mansion was it is it like a
big place or something
so my dad's probably in the top like a
half a percent of earners in the u.s and
and i have like nine siblings and we
grew up like traveling the world
like and it's literally like the coolest
thing because now
you know i grow i have these like so
everyone's like does well like my
brother makes like
90k at like 25. and like they're all
like super successful we have this like
really cool like family built
and i don't know like i think there's
some like value in that
so um well and i don't think any of us
really hated our parents
i mean they annoyed me sometimes but i
don't know
there's there's ways to do it all
my dad was one of nine he said he said
it would get that's a lot of people
but where um but you guys all so you
were just like living in a big mansion
together or something like that
yeah um well i grew up it's kind of a
weird story i grew up with six i was the
second of six that's like who was in the
house growing up
um my parents actually my dad knocked my
mom up at 18
and they just met so they gave that kid
up for adoption but we reunited with him
later
and then they adopted three teenagers
that were just in like bad situations
so that's that's like the dynamic
yeah i mean i could see well this is
like a weird
a weird comment i would think about i
was thinking about telling my channel
this at some point
but it almost feels like um it's a super
weird comp you have to think outside the
box it almost feels like
like some of the girls in the house like
take on some of the qualities of like
a family like in the sense of like
because i'm
it's almost like it's almost like me and
the in the main chick are like
like the mom and dad in a way like you
know because it's like
it's like my place and like i put this
together and all this [ __ ] so i kind of
like
you know i crack down on people when
people [ __ ] up and stuff like that but
she's like the number one chick
so she also like has like more authority
and stuff like this and um you know when
people [ __ ] up or make drama or whatever
it's
it's almost like a father yelling it's
strange
but but it's also rewarding in the sense
that you i feel like i'm like getting a
lot of those experiences even without
like a formal
yeah actual child you know i don't
i don't know i just can't imagine like
my mom is my best friend
now my mom knows everything so does my
dad i have like i'm like so close with
my parents
and my siblings like we all have like
really similar relationships with each
other
um and i just can't imagine getting that
like
from people i wasn't married or related
to because there's just some sense of
like
bond over knowing each other for like so
long you know
yeah yeah yeah but
what's interesting is is we feel on some
levels we all
we all have expressed this to each other
that we feel closer to each other
in a bunch of ways than we do to our own
families
you know just because we're we're
together all the time and we're
and we're having fun in your house
you're saying i thought me and you i was
like when did we talk
i was like
the whole audience here no but no no the
people in the house here
um you know because we're we're going
through like tragedies to get you know
something bad happens to one of us we
all go through it together and this and
that
and um you know whereas i'm more removed
from my my family's all in in the states
and stuff
and i'm not i'm not seeing them nearly
as much so and
the same is true for them like we all we
all have like a nice supportive
network together and stuff like that so
yeah it's it's
it's like new territory for sure because
i've never
uh cohabitated with more than just one
chick you know
typically before just like if it was a
living girlfriend or whatever but
with three are you an only child no i
was
uh one of four i was oldest of four okay
so i have to off to watch your house
tour though but was it weird was so many
like different personalities clashing
and stuff like that it was more like a
positive thing um well when they were
younger people cried a lot
because um i mean at the end of the day
like you know there's there's pros and
cons of a big family but one of the con
is like
um especially like the middle kids they
really want the attention
because like yeah obviously like
there's only so much to go around um
but yeah i don't know like when we
hit i don't know what age but when all
of us hit like
15 and up we just like started to get
along like me and my youngest sister
like
hated each other until we were like 13
and she's like 5 years younger than i
was 18.
and then after that now she's like one
of my best friends i call her all the
time
because we just can't relate to each
other in a way like we both
know i don't know we're raised the exact
same way
yeah yeah yeah what you said about the
middle child like
like the girl that was like the second
girl so it was like my main girl and
then the second girl came in
once the third girl came in the second
girl started almost like acting out
because because she was like losing
she was saying basically like you know
well liz that's like the main
the main one she's like well that's like
your main girl and now there's this new
girl in the house that like is exciting
and new and then she just felt like kind
of in limbo and it's like
it's like when a new child is born in a
family or so that's what i mean by the
the dynamics of a family almost creeping
in
you know even though it's not a real a
genetic family or whatever
it's it's still we're like linked
together by
living together and spending so much
time together and stuff like that but
yeah i mean it's interesting i i this
was like my ultimate goal in the game
was i want to live with a bunch of hot
girls
and that idea came from like hugh hefner
um and i'm watching his documentary
right now on amazon prime which is
pretty fascinating called like
american oops american playboy and
he talked about how he came from a very
conservative household and that
he didn't want to just have like a plain
vanilla life you know going down
the the white picket fence route and he
tried that at first and he was miserable
and so he started like challenging uh
normal conventions and normal ways of
living and stuff like this and then
i know he he came up like a playbook too
like like a guide
a set of rules and stuff like that which
i haven't been able to find yet but
that's gonna i think once i find that
that's gonna help
because he you know he he lived that
whole life with multiple girls like
a whole bunch of girls in the house and
constantly coming in and out and he
claims a
a lifetime late count of 2000 so
you're about to kill that but
hugh the rate of new girls has
definitely slowed
like i said like instead of going on new
dates all the time it's a lot of times
spending time with them
so i still see the the side rotation
ones a lot too but
in terms of like new dates it's hard to
fit those in without
with the you know the ones in the house
and all the side ones so
but again quality problems yeah
[Music]
well this was such a fun interview um
this is actually really interesting i've
never met
anyone um like you pretty much
that's like in that type of lifestyle so
it's really interesting to hear about
yeah i actually got asked i've never
been in any movies but i actually just
got asked
yesterday to be in an independent film
in la
about like a a big like playboy like
uh player type guy and they said that
they think that i would be better for
the roles
based on how i've conducted myself on my
youtube videos better than like a
hollywood actor because
i actually can authentically speak and
act since i actually did all that stuff
and they like so they want me to be like
the lead role for the
the guy it's about a guy that like falls
for like a milf that's like a challenge
because she's because she's older and
not not used to not similar to the types
of girls that he gets
so i have to like audition with them
over the
over zoom and read the read some of the
scripts and stuff like that but
that could be cool so are you gonna do
it
i think so that sounds dumb i wanna be
in a movie
yeah it's it's like this whole uh that
they're gonna they said just
like three months of filming um early
next year or whatever
but but but i would but it's what i hear
from all my like my clients and stuff
too a lot of the guys that sign up with
me is because they can
um they can sense that that it's all
authentic because this stuff really
happened like all the stuff i talk and i
show them
i show more proof to anyone as well but
even besides all the proof
just the way that i uh talk about this
stuff they said with a lot of the other
coaches their [ __ ] meter goes off
like pretty hardcore you you can
like when you look at like fresh from
fresh and fit you know
like stuttering around and making oh my
gosh i have said that and the comment
section
always says that i say that he seems
like fake
because um what because i i'm like it's
like shame insult guilt the need to be
right is like women
but i'm like no i just i don't i don't
get that like
vibe from him that he pulls chicks left
and right i think he's a hard worker
i think he's a good entertainer i think
um
you know i think i like a lot of the
self-improvement stuff he says i just
i don't i don't know the stuff he like
talks about i don't see it working that
well when it comes to pulling chicks
yep and yeah and even even all his his
theory and advice aside
the fact that he was working for wix.com
six months ago and has no like skin in
the game
in the sense of like oh that's the other
one that's the darker one right
um yeah yeah no i was talking about
myron
okay yeah they're both yeah they both
are fake
but yeah but people people said that
that i mean
with fresh he's the shorter one um
he was working for a website builder six
months ago i showed him that video about
him that he
paid for press releases where he's just
posing next to cars and
jets that aren't his paying for press
releases for for fake cred
um making all kinds of uh
fake claims just to build his image you
know just put on a ceo necklace and go
on camera
but you know it just shows what's
possible on the internet but again
i'm not knocking their hustle or their
you know their rise to fame and all this
stuff it's just they're just not real
dating experts
that's been my point all along is these
guys you know they're not getting hot
chicks without paying them
they're not experts or authorities on
the game that's
to me it doesn't matter how many subs
they have or anything else that that's
if we're talking about like them being
real gurus and dating absolutely not
well and that's why i think they'd
benefit more from like
learning from a guy like you and being
able to like re-teach some of the stuff
i don't know if there's a way you would
feel comfortable doing that without them
like
just stealing your stuff but like if i
was in their shoes i'd try to learn from
the best and then
like instead of trying to knocking him
you know
yeah well i mean he did he hit me up for
coaching two years ago
but he was he came across extremely
weird um
and i remember i texted alex i'm playing
with fire and i'm like what's what's the
[ __ ] what's this dude's deal
he wasn't popular at all yet and and
he's like yeah that guy's super weird he
always hits me up too asking for
coaching
i was like i'm not gonna coach him he's
trying to get coach for 500 bucks
and he was like he was just acting super
weird you could tell he was putting on a
big front
just the way he was talking and i was
like i don't want to do this guy
and now they're like you know these big
stars or whatever whatever you want to
call that
and even with money like i grew up with
a rich family i know
what people like how people with actual
money
that isn't going to be gone tomorrow act
like i just don't
i don't get that vibe from them i could
be wrong you know i'm not
i'm not i think i think they're actually
going to be like you said fake until you
make it i think with the money part
that was all front in the beginning but
i think they actually are
pulling in a piece of money now who
knows how much but one of them
apparently just bought a car
like a fast like a lambo or something
like that or a mclaren
was it i mean what i mean is like um
they just seem like miami like it's
gonna be they're today gone tomorrow
like because i don't know there's some
people i just get the vibe like as soon
as they get money they just spend it
but i could be wrong i don't know well
yeah i mean
they're that's they're trying to be the
cool guys yeah
if they're getting money then it's like
a tool to to be what they think is going
to
make
them cooler they're definitely they're
definitely use that and i know and i
know there's been a whole bunch of
reports of them
paying girls come on their shows and
stuff like that or paying girls to bang
them and then using that to try to brag
i've seen all kinds of stuff that i
haven't even published because a lot of
it's pretty [ __ ] up but guys send me
screenshots
you know from escort like this random
[ __ ] oh hey i like it like a guy from
miami hey there's this escort that i
bang and
uh she told me that she bangs myron and
he pays her this
amount this and that you know
whatever there's only so many [ __ ]
videos i can make showing that they're
[ __ ] losers
but someone said duh they both come from
modest immigrant backgrounds but here's
the thing like my dad was poor growing
up too
and it's like a mindset that you don't
spend everything you have
it's just like a mindset and if you
don't have it like the money comes and
it goes just as quick
yup but yeah yeah i'm gonna do more
uh reaction videos to their stuff for
sure
you should look up the the big one that
i was sent today
let me just pull it up real quick before
we make sure but basically um
it's like some instagram chick just
calling out all their [ __ ] saying that
they
where is it here um
oh here here it is so
it says you can see that it says uh
what's that nina unrated yeah
okay i've heard of her it explains how
she was sexually assaulted
but someone else was saying how they
were [ __ ]
yeah she bit she basically just like
blew up their [ __ ] and a bunch of girls
do this but the fans don't care
the fan the other day like you know it's
like if someone like
threw shade on jerry springer oh jerry
springer did this in his personal life
no one gives a [ __ ] they still like
they feel like his guests like throwing
chairs and the bouncer coming in to
break it up
which is sad but as just humans
i swear like a lot of my like best value
content in the sense of dating strategy
will get a lot of the lowest views and
if i just like attack someone
it'll just be like a smashing success
that's what people that's what people
want to see you should
you should react to kevin samuels i
would love to see that actually even
more than fresh and fit
because i i think kevin samuels is more
credible like he comes off as authentic
to me
okay he he was an image consultant he
worked in sales for like a long time
um i don't know his stuff comes off a
little bit more credible to me than
a lot of the red pill okay
yeah i can look i can look at i want i
want to start doing a lot more reaction
videos anyways people
you saw maybe i just like make jokes and
call people at retired
stuff like that do you have stream yards
[Music]
what's it called or stream
[Music]
oh stream labs not stream yards no i'm
streaming
oh stream labs will make your reaction
content so easy
like it's so easy like look up that
software
i could do like 10 reaction videos in
like two hours if i wanted to oh nice
but i like presents at night um it just
like
it use i i can't show you you can hook
it up to like your
um camera and then like just like
it's on the screen and your camera's
right there and then you just record it
there and then you can upload it right
to youtube so you don't have to edit it
at all
oh nice and yeah yeah i use like a
picture-in-picture thing now where i
just i can adjust the box
it's like my my uh box over the video
i don't know if you've seen any of those
that i've done um
i don't know i haven't seen your
reaction ones i've mostly watched like
your
game how to get girl stuff that's like
what i watched my one freshman fitter
all a lot of my reaction ones
where like the girls are destroying
their instagram or like they're doing
these
fake kickouts and stuff like that
yeah no i've seen i've seen a couple of
those um
but i would say oh you just spent that
stuff
okay yeah i've seen those yeah well
yeah look it up stream labs um
but yeah cool um but yeah thanks again
for having me on i appreciate it
yeah thanks so much for coming anybody
that's interested in my stuff check out
john anthony
lifestyle channel and also the
platinumdatingsystem.com if you're
interested in the mentorship which is a
free 30-minute call um
someone said i like you and that you
should watch out
somehow i'll manage i don't i don't know
how
i'd say whenever i whenever i like
interview with girls everyone's like oh
is he going to try to bang the girl
is he going to try to bang the post well
they'll say like they'll say like
simp that's like the main one if i talk
to a guy they always call that like that
they're something they're something
because they want to bang your your
audience probably wants to bang you and
then
they're like jealous so it's like
cognitive dissonance they can call the
guy a loser in a sim so they feel better
yeah i don't know i haven't thought
about it that much
yeah like you said you're in like a
mansion like that's the thing like you
said you're in like a
a nice place but then you look it looks
like just like a small thing because of
the
the blue the same with me like i record
in a little room of the
of the two-story penthouse because it
has the big desk
and then everyone's like oh he must be
in a basement i've done videos
where i like literally take the camera
and like show them the the [ __ ]
we're in on the water with the view and
everything but everyone
yeah i feel like people just like to
talk trash online
yeah i mean this room is small that i'm
in but you do it for the sound like it
makes better sound quality the smaller
the room
so yeah yeah for me it's just the desk
there's another big desk in the house
yeah
or room that would be suitable really so
um cool so yeah we'll stay in touch
we'll we'll definitely organize another
collab
it's fun okay thanks for watching guys
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
and john's channel while you're at it
and i will talk to you guys next time